[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome welcome welcome to the
screen junkies movie bytes extravaganza
benefiting women in film it is going to
be an awesome event and thank you so
much to you out there we almost lost a
leg but it's gonna work out thanks to
you we have raised over $36,000 for
women and fell advocate for women in the
entertainment industry and that's what
we are all about tonight to be a great
night of fights including some of your
host Roxie shires here the epic return
of Alicia Malone and a clap
Daniel Radford with all the judges hello
short charge and you know what you can
still donate go to screen junkies comm
backslash charity event capital C
capital E you can donate and people are
so we're gonna do a special shout out to
Cameron Lindsay five hundred dollar
donation Stephen - gotta lea fruits
watching from europe thank you so much
we'll be calling you out throughout the
night it's gonna be a great show how
Rudnick is here and here's a little bit
of what you can expect this is screen
junkies movie fights a battle field of
cinephile debate we're winners find
glory through facts passion creativity
and sometimes because they shouted
loudest tonight gear up for the single
biggest movie fights event of all time
where challengers from across the
internet will gather for an extravaganza
to benefit women in film fan favorites
will Duke it out in two lightning-quick
glass fighter standing gauntlet things
get critical when some of the best movie
critics in the biz turn their critical
eye on each other
gathered your magical girl pals and
crank it over 9000 because it's the
first-ever anime fight never before
never again our two-time Emmy nominated
honest trailers team goes head to head
pride is on the line as Nerdist hyper
heroes and Rotten Tomatoes wage war over
the future of the MCU from movie talk to
movie fights
it's a Collider collision as Collider
collides Young Lions cucumber and chunk
step into the ring with veteran ring
general hashtag Botanica spike Carlson
the living legend Alicia Malone returns
to oversee a family feud in the equally
legendary House Moulton Plus Doug loves
movies bites Nick Mundy gets raw scoops
Magee breaks the news TV and gamer
fights return for one night only
you made this show possible you made it
happen so sit back strap in and get
ready for boobie bites extravaganza and
now your host for the first fight of the
night how rudnick what's going on
everybody it is the movie fights live
again and what better way to start off
the women in film extravaganza than with
four do the greatest crossover in
history here it is I can't believe these
three guys Spencer Gilbert Joestar dan
Murrow I give you a round of applause
the men behind honest trailers you've
never fought before and we're going down
on cam right but you three have not
movie fought against each other and
we're gonna do that right now are you
feeling it are you ready let's do this
hey Danielle you guys feeling it we're
feeling all of you men your favorite men
thank you all right men guys here's the
dumb question what's the dumbest movie
ever made that is the question Spencer
Gilbert
with you my movies called Tammy and the
t-rex how it's a unseen gem and to
explain why it's dumb I'll just start
briefly by explaining the human brain to
you guys you see the brain is composed
of three distinct layers on the outside
you have the human brain responsible for
reasoning poetry philosophy art you have
the mammalian brain which has just some
more basic socialization aspects but
then at the core at the dumbest part of
us all you have the lizard brain just
responsible for fight/flight and
fornication and no movie speaks to those
basic instincts more than Tammy and the
t-rex I'll explain more later but what's
your picture first of all I just really
appreciate that dance sort of taking
notes immediately as you just started
describing the human brain so I'm really
I want to see how that comes into play
working on a thesis once upon a time a
dumb man who doesn't know anything about
dwarves decided to write a drama about a
family of dwarves except for one son
played by Matthew McConaughey
this was a very dumb idea that movie's
called tiptoes a bunch of a-list actors
yep look at the script and they said
yeah okay which was dumb and it's the
little very dumb tagline Thank You
Spencer
and then they cast Peter Dinklage in
this movie about dwarves but instead of
making him the lead a very dumb agent
called Gary Oldman said here's how we're
gonna give you an Oscar you're gonna sit
around and walk on your knees with a bad
mullet wig next to Peter Dinklage and in
a very dumb decision Gary Oldham said
yeah okay tiptoes tiptoes from Joestar
Dan Morrell dumbest movie ever made
Aaron Eckhart to quote him from The Dark
Knight once said you either die a hero
or you live long enough to become the
villain and that's what I think of every
time I think of my pick for the dumbest
movie ever made the fourth film and the
jaws franchise jaws the revenge this
time it's personal
there is so much about this movie that
is mind-numbing ly dumb that I can't
wait to get into and
I just let's just continue with the
fight so I can get to how many ways this
movie is the stupidest dumbest movie
ever made
heck yeah mix it up fellas I'd like to
because no one let's be real no one's
seen Tammy and the t-rex this is an
unearthed gem I'd like to very quickly
run you guys through the plot if I could
yeah because the movie stars a Tammy a
pre Fame Denise Richards and Mike a pre
Fame Paul Walker and though we yeah and
the weekend at Bernie's guy it's a love
triangle between a Tammy Mike and Billy
her abusive ex-boyfriend Mike and Billy
get in a fight where all they do is
squeeze each other's testicles for about
five minutes straight JT I believe we
have a clip Paul Walker is abducted by
Billy in the gang and left in a the
town's local wild animal sanctuary where
he's mauled by a lion JT I believe we
have a clip
let me movie fight like no one's ever
movie fun at that point is bald buddies
abducted by doctor watch enstein where
he's put in an animatronic dinosaur one
thing leads to another he becomes a
dinosaur he reunites with his girlfriend
Tammy who doubts that's him until he
does his signature move which is to eat
flowers I it's hard to explain but just
watch walker doing it and there's the
dinosaur doing it so you know it's you
know what in 1994 it was a smart idea to
do combine dinosaurs and dumb Polly
short comedy because the two biggest
things in the world Richard Rasik park
and friggin Pauly Shore combine those
two ideas that's like where's Pauly
Shore it's Paul Walker how dare he's not
as good a style of comedy I understand
that Paul Walker's mom did not dominate
the LA comedy scene for years and years
and then let her son make son-in-law
Queen
like these are these are this is a good
these are good things to combine in 1994
and they did a competent job doing it
they didn't do a dumb job they did an
okay job you know what that ball grab
joke
it ends with Paul Walker saying I was
wearing a cup and that that's dumb
it's a welcome it's not well it's a
completed joke whereas whereas whereas
tiptoes is just dumb tiptoes does not
even get to I was wearing a cup tiptoes
is just the ball grabbed but for 90
minutes that's the prize tiptoes is
actually like a pretty nuanced
interesting movie it just happened to
cast Gary Oldman that's the holy dumb
thing about it no no no is there's
multiple three-dimensional little people
characters which is more than you can
say about most movies there's no nuance
to a scene where someone says to a
pregnant woman hey have you been
drinking of course not I'm pregnant and
then there's a 30-second pause and then
she says do you want to go get some
drinks and then they go yes this movie
was not written it was just it was just
made somehow complete a joke to meet you
yeah well you know just the revenge Joss
the revenge to speak about just a little
mate first of all okay Spencer took us
through a symposium on his movie yes
exactly and my movies so dumb I don't
need clips I could just tell you how
stupid it is Joss revenge is about the
wife of Roy Scheider's character from
the first movie who the shark kills one
of their sons and he she goes with the
other son to the Bahamas I looked this
up 1038 nautical miles away and the
shark somehow follows them there it's
never explained how or why a shark can
navigate from the northeast part of the
United States to the Bahamas secondly
this shark again not the same shark not
even the second or third same shark from
the other movies somehow has made it
personal against the people in this
movie who by the way have done nothing
to any of the other sharks in the
franchise so even if you're gonna
the right that the concept of a shark
wanting revenge on somebody is not the
dumbest premise of all time even the
revenge itself is dumb because he's
going after people that didn't do
anything - well they're related best
idea in the history it's not dumb Dan
it's nuanced I like that they don't hit
you they don't hit you over the head
with the Sharks connection to the widow
they just they there's no connection is
dead dumb movie would have liked a dead
zone moment where the shark and the lady
look at each other and you're like oh I
get it per cycle he connected this movie
just as logical you're a brilliant film
critic and a very perceptive man I'm
shocked that you missed the subtext of
this whole movie the shark is a metaphor
this is a woman's grief following her
across the ocean you're telling me if
you steer a sailboat into the side of
grief it explodes oh my gosh Wow three
super dumb movies longer yes sir got
twice the time to bring Clips you know
bang your shoe on the table if you don't
like if you just let them go as opposed
to PowerPoint presentation you're the
host it's your job not mine
you know what I let him argue so
[Laughter]
so from where I'm sitting Spencer
knocked you out with his lovely metaphor
dan I'm so sorry that that shark was a
woman's pain your movie was super dumb
and your movie was super dumb
I feel like Joe put the Jo squashed you
with that punter asset Park Pauly Shore
comment that what you saw in that movie
was in the zeitgeist I give it to Joe
and tiptoes well I think the facts are
good how as far as I could tell that is
in fact how sharks biologically operate
I gotta say it very hard because Spencer
I thought lost the fight by enticing me
to see his film with those clips a
little bit but then he came back and
gave a hard knock to Dan who had all
that passion I gotta say dance passion
won me over I'm going down all right
it's one-one Joe and Dan Joe and dad
Danielle oh I hate this first of all all
of your movies are dumb and I'm gonna
watch all of them this weekend you know
I am um I you know Dan his point about
the shark stalker is a very strong point
like how does a shark stalk someone but
that metaphor about a woman's grief
really got me I have to go with Spencer
[Applause]
three smart guys three dumb movies
congratulations Joe we'll do it again
honest trailer bragging rights you know
what today is a spectacular momentous
day we're catching up with friends old
and new and we have a little bit of
something from Oh a good friend of ours
who's about to get a little bit raw and
welcome to a very special episode of
Monday Night Raw my name is Nick Mundy
and never say you can't make a comeback
for charity and only for charity with me
as always as my very very special boy I
miss him I've been writing letters to
him he finally responded mr. dan Murrow
hey Nick hey see you you too it's been
like two years for real it's yes it has
been this is kind of like a recurring
nightmare that I've yeah so we're doing
the Monday Night Raw
look at that we thought we'd never do
this again yeah the only way this could
be a worse idea is if you made a stand
and there was only two of us you ruined
me fights I changed it back I think we
should start the show let's do it let's
start it Dan I guess we're reviewing a
movie because that's what we do here
that is what we did well well infinity
wars out you know what were you infinity
where you and me how about this like old
times
all right a vintage infinity war of
course as you know is in theaters now I
had the biggest opening weekend of any
movie globally or domestically of all
time directed by the Russo brothers who
as you know did Captain America the
Winter Soldier
and this is the culmination of ten years
Marvel movies this is of course an
adaptation of the very popular what do
you what are you doing Nick what do you
mean what's with the what's this it's a
pity about what that's okay that's the
if anything yeah do you want people to
see this we're I'm making the thumbnail
for the show oh okay do you want people
to see this thing I do we add this for
charities so yeah it's for charity this
is how people see stuff through the
thumbnail every other movie boy is doing
the Thanos glove thing in the thumbnail
you want people see that you're not I am
okay two years is a place ago but I'm
trying to get the thumbnail done that's
fine don't have patience for this stuff
that's fine then you've it's for if
you're right you're right so keep dues
you're just I mean it's a pity golly man
so Josh Brolin is a place-- fan oh so
the wielder of the Infinity Gauntlet he
has in search of the Infinity stones
which are magical gems that will give
him
unlimited power across the galaxy now
what I what I really what is this neck
what do you what are you why are you
stopping it's very I don't know what
you're doing why
what if Logan was in the affinity war
thumbnail man this is a supplementary
video do you want views man's a - I did
you know have a YouTube algorithms work
I don't know if there you see lowing
claws in the nails JT get this close up
and then infinity war text in bold
letters and some guys like and then
other ones like come on I mean how do
you seen your channel I have all right
Infinity Ward Logan thumbnail JT one two
three picture ah what would you give
this movie I you know I really like this
movie I thought that it was a good
addition to Marvel Cinematic Universe
I'm gonna give it a solid b-plus all
right yeah I thought the movie jakie hit
it
Nik Mundi national treasure boom glad to
see on my pal all right it's time for
the first speed round gauntlet of this
behemoth okay so here's how it works I
will throw out a donor submitted
question thank you for submitting your
questions each person first person to
answer will speak and then what will
speak first and then they'll have 20
seconds 20 seconds ten seconds ten
seconds rebuttal okay 20 20 and then ten
ten and then we're gonna go through this
all night long
you are the first match of the gauntlet
I will decide the winners and yeah this
is so exciting we've got Schmo down
champion Brianne Chen vs. spider-man
homecoming Tony rather Laurie
Wow all right yes superstar indeed all
right lady gentlemen here is your
question submitted by Brian Burton what
failed either critically or commercially
what failed movie either critically or
commercially most is in most need of a
remake what failed movie is in most need
of a remake tick-tock we only have three
hours so we have as much time as the
Oscars pretty much Green Lantern Green
Lantern labyrinth is that a failed one
that's what you said great all right we
heard Green Lantern first tony is
arguing for Green Lantern Brienne for
labyrinth 20 seconds begin Tony whenever
you speak Ryan Reynolds is perfect as
Deadpool but he missed the mark as Hal
Jordan and Green Lantern I would love to
see Green Lantern come back with a Jon
Stewart and have someone like Idris Elba
come in and reinvigorate the franchise
of the Green Lantern because they are
such an iconic part of time 20 seconds
oh yeah
so labyrinth it's a great classic from
the 80s that I feel could be updated
especially with its special effects and
I find that it will be interesting it's
somewhat of a musical and I would like
to take it even more into the musical
genre and make it like a great a showman
labyrinth because I love great a showman
and I would just like to see something a
little more showy 10 second rebuttal
labyrinths will never be better than
what it was with David Bowie in that so
you can never remake that movie because
David Bowie is great Green Lantern needs
to be made because it was a terrible
movie and it needs to be remade so that
way the DCU it was a terrible movie
therefore I feel like it doesn't really
need to be remade because we have so
much superhero saturation I would just
like to see something different for once
that goes back to our roots of time
wow what a battle I love the idea of
address elbows the Jon Stewart Green
Lantern I hate the idea of greatest
showmen labyrinth a lot of fun already
guys we're celebrating an amazing cause
and now the women of screen junkies are
gonna break it down and tell you oh
what's that
[Applause]
come to the party pal oh man all right
Tony verse edy gauntlet gauntlet I'm
business money
this is submitted by our own Keith
Richmond what else Keith Keith Richard
watches the show no no I guess Keith
Richards and Mick Jagger watch the show
open aidable keith richmond asks what is
the best movie musical ever made no I'm
from the peanut gallery hmm I'll say
Chicago Chicago gonna go Greece Greece
we have Chicago first Greece and you
smoke first 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak now I think a Chicago is even
more relevant now because we're more
into female issues and whatnot and the
the contrast between Catherine
zeta-jones character and Renee
Zellweger's character and far as far as
how they live life and how they learn
from each other and the jail experience
I think that was really great also it's
got great songs even sums were other
people like mr. cellophane bye-bye john
c reilly
i remember that that's crazy time
Greece is a timeless Catholic that will
never ever be out of style people watch
it to this day every year every month
people love this movie
you have John Travolta in height of his
fame and Olivia newton-john creating
songs that are incredible at the height
of John Travolta's Fame and the musical
is just something that you always want
to have in your heart because it's so
warm and and and and hopeful I think it
was very warm and helpful when you hear
the lyrics tell me more tell me more
does she put up a fight
oh my god they should put up a fight on
this date why were you defeated begins
Chicago is the movie that I don't even
know because Greece is something that
kids watch even nowadays it's on
Broadway Chicago is nowhere near so it's
not a time I got to give it to Ed Grier
for the strong no character and knock
him down grease questionable lyric Tony
River Laurie thanks for shopping pal
all right let's welcome to the chair
Riley Silverman go on go on
lick my waist for the difference preach
to strong female characters a Batman
style character and Adrian Smith is in
that yeah okay this this question Edie
Riley ready to do battle Fionna
Henderson submitted what is the best
Edgar Wright movie Shaun of the Dead
okay so then I have to go Scott Pilgrim
all right Shawn first Scott and spoke
first 20 seconds begin when you speak
now
Shana the dead did not fall into the
same traps there's a lot of other comedy
horror movies I think they established
the rules of the reality fairly quickly
and I think every time that they do
something silly with the zombie concept
it's a metaphor for something in reality
ie the the grogginess of everybody in
the morning that that whole sequence
that throw in the records you know
there's a lot of things in there that
are really cool that's a great zombie
movie antegrade comedy movie he's great
Riley free words for you Mary Elizabeth
Winstead that's my first thing Ramona
flowers lots of crazy hair colors lots
of fun to watch also just a lot of fun
taking like the idea of the video game
movie which we have seen tried over and
over again and failed and instead we
take a movie it's based on a comic book
but used all the videogame tropes in a
way that actually like it's really
engaging interesting and kind of
challenges the genre a little bit breaks
the fourth wall rebuttal I would
certainly give Scott comer a certain
amount of credit as far as being uh
trying to be some of the innovative
movie but to take your rightful place on
the throne of one of the best zombie
movies of all time after all the other
zombie movies to come out and a comedy
come on man listen but Scott Pilgrim has
to line up itself against all of Edgar
Wright's other exes and defeat them in
battle and that's what it goes forth and
does and fights its own self at the end
just like Scott fighting his own self
you two made this very hard for me and I
don't like that but I gotta go I gotta
go
ed every course you do
as far as the better film overall not
even argument that's the better movie
Reilly don't sell yourself short you a
strong ed was just stronger Thank You
Riley
thanks for shopping all right and get
ready to face the Florida bull Jay
Washington versus the thing here we go
like that Bulls had I just came back
from Chicago damn right Jack Kirby
should draw this match the hole versus
the thing okay this question is
submitted by Roman Kauffman what was the
worst performance to win best actor or
actress Oscar
Al Pacino in Scent of a Woman Al Pacino
in Scent of a Woman Jay
boss actress or actor house very muscle
ball Halle Berry versus Al Pacino a
match made in Hades can you spoke first
edie there was a time when Al Pacino was
one of our greatest actors but during
this period he slipped into a very a
very dinner theater style of acting
where he just sort of screamed
everything as though it was important
and that movie was was very emblematic
of their Wow and we know that there's a
watch that got job doubt that year
because he was he was the best actor
that year so I'm most people agree that
that at least Enzo got job doubt when it
comes to Halle Berry monsters ball we
just more so connect her to Billy Bob
Thornton we connect the performers being
horrid especially the fact like she did
losing Isiah it was just a sequel to do
in that performance we wanted better
which we ended up getting better out of
Halle Berry granny she had the fallback
with Catwoman but that fact they're
monsters bothers it made me feel good
everybody hated that but just like to
see the scene with the two of them
together
Al Pacino does Al Pacino which is drugs
now when you come rebuttal my Roberto
would be that yes Halle Berry's
performance was horrid but the very fact
is there was a big I don't hate to say
it but a diversity push and she got she
got put over but it was a Lifetime
Achievement Award for album you know Al
Pacino started going on that downward
slide he did scent of a woman he had the
performance attending of a Sunday but
Halle Berry elevated her claims until
she got the cab woman which we all want
burnt at the stake and act like it never
happened but when he comes to Halle
Berry performances you want Wow what I
call what a collision
yeah you're right Catwoman is bad but Al
Pacino's performance instead of the
woman is the one that takes the day
right here yeah we talked a little too
much about Halle Berry's other films and
you're absolutely right Denzel deserved
it for Malcolm X that year
[Music]
[Laughter]
the last fight of this riveting gauntlet
will involve mr. mark and Draco and
every alright the final question of the
gauntlet is submitted by Page Brigante
what form of animation lends itself
better for film 2d hand-drawn or 3d CG
and Ron hand-drawn from the comic book
artist that leaves you with the 3d CG
Edie formulate your opinion mark and
draco spoke first twenty seconds begins
when you speak CG is great for
environments and symmetrical things but
in real life living creatures aren't
symmetrical and it becomes very cold and
very distant I would much rather watch
Beauty and the Beast or Snow White in
the Seven Dwarfs then Toy Story any day
of the week because there's it's almost
like Ray Harryhausen special effects you
like the human touch the imperfections
make it feel more real more real and
more present there's a stair there's a
stair Allah t2 CG and records have a
richer sound than CDs or mp3s I mean
come on I I just feel as though the
advancements that are in 3d animation
when you see The Incredibles especially
even The Incredibles - the things that
they're able to do with the textures
that they're able to do with a CGI I
mean I just think they're superior to a
lot of hand-drawn animation which tends
to be a little bit repetitive even in
the best examples of it so I do believe
that the environments it might be so it
might be much sleeker and more more
polished but if you're talking about
records being an archaic
you know what outsold CDs and DVDs and
digital last year vinyl so sometimes the
original is the best one I think the
need to go back to butter churns and
things of this nature is part of us
weird anachronistic people but in
reality as far as movie animation I do
believe the CGI is is superior at this
point body blows and roundhouses what a
battle that was at the end of the day I
gotta go Ed Grier
[Applause]
and you with Reggie with record sales
but you came back with the butter churns
and you know what I feel your first I
thought your I thought your first round
argument really was set up something
fairly unbeatable Wow
[Applause]
insanity mark and Drake oh well done
I'll be at the bar okay you know what
you might have deja vu and thank you ed
edd excellent ed come over here and hang
out with me while I read this yeah so I
had it's been such a great night already
wouldn't you agree I think so yeah oh
yeah getting finder I find your camera
yeah here we go but you know I want to
learn a little bit more about this night
and the women of screen junkies are
going to break down what exactly the
women in film organization is and what
they're all about they put together a
sweet video let's check it out I'm a
member of Women in Film and one of the
many reasons that I love being part of
this group is because it has a great
networking vibe there are always
screenings events mixes and it's a
chance for people who are up-and-coming
in the industry to actually get to meet
them Mentors
this business can be incredibly
difficult to break into but a lot of
times the best way to get into the door
is if someone else sees you and says I'm
going to show you how to get this done
I'm gonna take you under my wing when
you have something set into place where
it's women helping women it's women that
are already there opening the space
wider for someone next to them that
person then widens the space for
somebody else underneath them women in
film does so many things your money goes
to so many different places and one of
the places that I think is most
important is their hotline so that if
they are being sexually harassed in
their workplace they have somebody to
talk to they are building a foundation
for women to feel supported I think it's
just absolutely invaluable for women to
know that these programs exist and if
you have women in film doing things like
offering film financing workshops
whether they're giving finishing fun
for movies that maybe just couldn't
quite cross that finish line they're
gonna provide several filmmakers with
the money to actually finish their film
that's what gets it into festivals
that's what gets their career going
that's what gets us to be able to see
the film in the first place or if it's a
mentorship program where you get to
speak to another producer who maybe has
walked this road before and can teach
you things you didn't know yet and
people need that information a lot of
times just how to navigate the business
itself more than they need the idea I
could I can use both frankly those are
just a few things that women in film
does thank you so much for your support
and thanks for watching thank you guys
so much for your support you are
literally the best
you
what a great cause and what a great
night I'm Sasha pearl raver coming to
you from deep in the movie fight studio
and I am joined by your Hydra
nerdfighters who are coming up next got
Dan Casey
Jacqueline Coley hector Navarro and of
course we got our judging girl we got
some major controversy on this couch Tom
Lennon
gentlemen how do we feel about that
first gauntlet because there was I did
not see that got stressed me out that
stressed me out Sasha stairs Madeline I
feel like you also had a lot of
questions and answers the animation
round I've saw a vein pop out of his
neck that was a completely unfair BS
question whoever I know I know we love
the screen junkies fans but whoever
asked that it's just a medium that was
BS that was total BS unfair answer both
both come on the greatest animated film
of all time the Iron Giant has a CG
character at the center of it it depends
on how you use it it's all depending on
how you use it people Coco these are
gone you got extremely upset about the
mention of the greatest show Oh Lord the
McDonald's of musicals I'm sorry you
know it is though it's so the boyfriend
that I broke up with because I hated
that movie when it came out and they
just keeps getting hotter and get better
girlfriends cuz that movie made so much
money it's McDonald's of musical quit
eating it quit ingesting this awful
movie so Jacqueline's talking about
because chicken nuggets are yummy and
that's sweet sour sauce dick Casey how
are you feeling about going into this
next fight how do you feel about this
whole day in general Scent of a Woman I
don't have a sense of smell so I can't
relate to any women a film is a
wonderful cause I'm happy to be a part
of this raising awareness for a
fantastic organization well how about
going up against these fighters who do
you feel most intimidated by well I've
had thank you I had a dream about this
I feel intimidated by both them for
different reasons because I respect them
very much and I know that each one of
them is going to smack me down in a way
that it will just leave a lasting mark
so some sort of like weird sent to our
hybrid of the two of them I have a
feeling that when I try to make a very
good real reasoned argument it's just
gonna get eviscerated like so many
Hulk's in so many old man Logan's
cleanest thing to look at all this love
before it goes down now where can the
good people find you if they have
something to say about your fight oh no
you can find me online at dan casey also
by my brand new Star Wars book in stores
now I'm that Jacqueline cuz I'm that
girl on the internet so it's pretty easy
to find me anywhere there Hector I'm at
Hector's funny because I assumed white
people wouldn't remember my last name
who's going to get new movie fights
championship belts but before we do any
of that we're going to throw it over to
our girl Roxy who's got our anime fight
take it girl yeah so much ever before
especially when it wasn't even fought in
a round very well Nobby talk girl is
here for anime show men aren't you
prepared for that yeah I know all about
PT Barnum Bethel Connecticut solidarity
man before he's born that's where I was
know the best number from that is the
other side I know that the zendaya
number would make an amazing fight today
guys I'm Roxy striker in case you forgot
because we haven't been here and a
little bit alongside Emma Philo happy to
be here talking about some anime and
we've got some great nerds on the couch
to do my job for me cuz they know all
about anime is back so
[Applause]
you know I'm you love them it's Joestar
hey guys got the minute they got the my
god okay let's get into the actual fight
because me Joe stumble over what his
favorite anime is we're here to talk
about what is the best anime series of
all time Emma we are starting with you
all right listen guys there have been
many fantastic anime series over the
years a lot of people have a lot of
nostalgia for like 80s anime and 90s
anime but let me take you back to the
year 1977 or actually beginning with the
manga the anime started in 1978 this is
the year that Star Wars was released but
also one of the most important space
operas of all time
galaxy express 3 9 this is the
coming-of-age journey of young tetsuro
who finds a way to get himself a ticket
on board the galaxy Express 3 9 which is
a train that goes throughout the
universe with the help of a mysterious
beautiful woman named it may tell who
you don't have some deep dark secrets
obviously like you do and it's a journey
through the galaxy to ultimately get
what everybody wants which is a machine
body through a machine body you're able
to preserve all of your thoughts and
emotions and essentially achieve
immortality of course along his journey
stopping at many different planets along
the way tetsuro realizes that getting a
machine body might not be all it's
cracked up to be which is a hard lesson
that I think all of us need to learn
this is truly a series that is ahead of
its time that in addition to being a
coming-of-age story really warns against
the troubles of capitalism ok ok first
of all I'd like to bring out a gift for
us to share because at the end though
we're just two girls that are really
happy to be talking about anime because
like I got to do this in high school man
yeah man ok super it's a good flavor
tale I decided to go with Cowboy Bebop
which is the adventure the bounty hunter
crew of the bebop
the ultimate space Western I'm a brown
goat and yes I still think that is the
case so the Cowboy Bebop is the best of
both Eastern and Western storytelling
each episode is a perfect standalone
narrative but with a beautiful
overarching character arc so you can
really see each of them on their own but
taking it as an aggregate you get a
really lovely character development
it's an incredible ensemble cast the
animation is great they poured tons of
money into animation and into the
soundtrack the soundtrack is incredible
and iconic the OCO kana and the
seatbelts jazz and it's and it's so
beautiful and timeless more than
anything timeless also the voice acting
both in the Japanese original and in
English dubbing they took time and money
in order to make it quality this is the
kind of stuff that is used as the bar
for dubbing to this day also I it's it's
Galaxy Express is fantastic in that it
was ahead of its time as you said but it
was still very early in development of
the medium the animation itself is not
very great the voice acting is not great
the I in the English version I would
like to point out the Japanese version
even in the original Japanese I'm sorry
are you arguing that Masako Nozawa the
voice of tetsuro also the voice of Goku
is not a good voice actor is
I'm sorry Davis masala it is literally
worth watching this movie in Japanese
simply for her performance she is one of
the great voice actors of all time
nobody is gonna argue that she is not
one of the best in the business she's
eternal boy unless the thing is it's not
about her performance it's about the
quality of the dubbing they didn't have
the time to match the lip flap because
like the way that anime was dubbed in
the olden days is they just kind of play
it back and like hope for the best that
they caught something because the
quality of the the tape would degrade
the more that you go back and try and
dub it better and so if you watch it
it's not about her performance it's
about the quality like the lip flats
just man lips don't quite match up that
doesn't change the fact that she gives
an incredibly emotional performance as
Tetsuro tetsuro is very much the heart
of the entire Matsumoto verse and that
is the thing is that Leiji Matsumoto the
creator of galaxy Express 39 has an
entire body of work that is all centered
around this you know it started with you
created space battleship yamato back in
1974 and then in 1977 launched both
galaxy express 3:9 and so captain
harlock the original cool anime guy come
on so you can take a look at the
aggregate of galaxy express and all the
different films and like the hundred and
thirteen plus episodes of the TV but if
you look at Cowboy Bebop in its 26
perfect episodes with one movie the
quantity and broadness of the universe
does not necessarily equal cause I'm
gonna talk about the fact there's a
blaxploitation episode of Cowboy Bebop
yeah absolutely Cowboy Bebop is a love
letter to Western cinema there is a
blaxploitation there is some high films
there's westerns there's some Godard if
you're into French new-wave local
happenings it's not what is are you are
you saying that it's racist because it
shows in me I would just I would just
like you to go talk to like marquis 'or
somebody about the blaxploitation
episode which is mushroom samba it
definitely is you know portraying black
people in a way that is very
stereotypical it is definitely
representation however it is not
inclusion the other issue that I have
with Cowboy Bebop and I love Cowboy
Bebop don't get me wrong it is a great
series but what is it about okay what I
thought Erica you can answer her
question or use your time however you
want
cowboy bebop first of all I think we
don't need to have a show that is about
anything in particular there are plenty
of shows that don't have like a
through-line that are incredible cowboy
bebop is a ensemble character study like
you could argue that fireflies not about
anything or any friends is about nothing
or so many other shows that are just
about nothing but the quality of
storytelling isn't impacted by that I
think Seinfeld's us the show about
nothing here's the thing is I'm all I
I'm in complete agreement something
doesn't have to be about something in
order for it to be a good piece of art
however in in galaxy express to be nine
you get not only again Erika you bring
up the idea of all of these individual
episodic standalone episodes that's
exactly what you have in galaxy Express
three nine each episode is an individual
look in Tesoro's ultimate journey of
getting to the point that he realizes
that getting a robot body is not all
that it is cracked up to be if you get a
machine body that is sacrificing your
humanity there is a scene where they go
to the planet of Pluto and there is a
and you know anyway ultimately it is it
is about a hero's journey it is about
the journey from being a kid to an adult
and my god have you seen the eyelashes
on the women in Leiji Matsumoto works
hashtag eyelash goals oh I need some
good eyelashes right about now max I'm
sure you can agree with me what are you
thinking over there you get one vote Joe
you get one as well cowboy bebop only
because it as much as galaxy 39 is you
would say historically a ground changing
groundbreaking anime Cowboy Bebop is
more so for Western audiences and if
we're talking about being an anime geek
in America you got to give it up for a
cowboy bebop and just pounce on these
arguments based on those arguments mmm
yeah you don't get to just but the whole
thing is is you know the whole like the
dub is also very good I mean just
technically is very very well put
together it's one of like just the best
produce all right Joe what are you
thinking I thought look I later on in
the fight Emma came out really hard
on themes and sort of the structure of
the show and how they supported those
but even at the beginning of the fight
look I'm a white male nerd and so I am
genetically encoded to love a really
good well actually and emma v came in
with real hard with though with those
casting well actually is at the
beginning so i got to go with them
bummer about that if you guys make me do
my job right now i've got really strong
points across the table and it got a
little heated which is what we love here
on an anime fights i think that although
there were strong points on both sides
like i said i think that there were just
a couple of more that i heard from emma
rebutting bebop so am i you get this for
me
[Applause]
you're wondering if I was offered any
Pocky I was not it's in front of you now
judge as we go to the balcony Roth and
Leonard and Jessie Moulton and some
other special people that was an awesome
anime fight thank you so much Roxy and
team and I am here I am honored to be
here with legendary film critic
mr. Leonard Maltin legend in her own
right Jessie Moulton is here yes and you
know him you love him
that's mr. Greg Miller game over Greg
Ian what I want to talk about is people
take their movie fights pretty seriously
nowadays and I'm wondering how it's been
for you in terms of film criticism
people talking back on Twitter that
interaction do you think it's a good
thing or we've become sort of polarized
well obviously some of us become
polarized and some people are just
looking for a fight they're raring to go
I'm the opposite I mean I don't mind
differences of opinion I got no problem
with that but I don't want to spend my
life talking about what I've just opened
it you know I mean that's my opinion
that's all it is just an opinion take it
or leave it
wise words in the night of movie fights
very well Jessie do you have epic movie
fights at home what are you looking for
it she said you're going mano a womano
with your dad
mano a womano no we don't have fights
because he knows better he doesn't he
lives in a house of women so he just
doesn't bother because what do you know
it's a happy wife happy life well he's
got happy wife happy daughter happy life
about sums it up
Greg you have been in this space for a
long time so you've been dealing with
the fan community I'm always amazed at
how well you interact with your fans
have you had big trouble around things
like infinity war or how do you handle
all that no I mean I think you reap what
you sow a lot with an internet community
and kind of funny we're super lucky that
we say hey we want to be positive as I
punched
we want to be positive we want that kind
of interaction we want to have a
positive discourse and if you don't
that's fine we're just not the place for
you
what are you guys looking forward to
most of all tonight just doing it
d'arnot just doing it we're completely
unrehearsed as you know so anything can
happen anything can happen but I have a
strong feeling we're gonna learn a lot
from you how about you Greg I'm looking
forward to hugging Leonard Maltin let's
make that happen right about now
remember you guys can still donate this
entire event everything is thanks to you
we owe you such a debt of gratitude
we love this audience we love this
community we want to thank especially
you have donated live right now Albert
we're Dharma he and McAndrew Sean Patton
Audie
thank you so much for your continued
support you can donate at screen junkies
dot-com backslash charity event capital
C capital lead let's keep on rockin in
with a hyper nerdfighting all right
Thank You Rob and I salute Leonard
Maltin he is on the Mount Rushmore of
film critics okay we've got a super
nerdy fun segment right now we're gonna
throw down four nerd cred and we've got
some esteemed nerds with us first
welcome to have Hector Navarro here
thank you so much everybody I'm happy to
be here oh right next to him Jacqueline
Coley from Rotten Tomatoes hi her hair
is so big Dan Casey from the Nerdist
thank you for having me help hell yeah
all right oh we got a crazy question
right now what character that has not
debuted yet should become the anchor of
the MCU wowie
all right Hector we're gonna start with
you
all right good to go mm-hmm okay so
here's what's gonna happen we're gonna
get a guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
then afterwards so far as far as we know
there's no space centric Marvel
Cinematic Universe film on top of that
spider-man homecoming is killing it
everybody loves that young energy that
Tom Holland brings to the whole world
everybody loves seeing a teenage
character growing up in a world of
superheroes since he's been 8 years old
Iron Man's been a thing so my pitch is I
brought visual aids is my dude right
here Nova specifically Sam
Alexandr for very very specific reasons
look not even in the right Nova but I'll
allow it
you're not gonna we're not gonna day
that's not we're not gonna disregard our
great comic-book character but as you
can see but what I just said it's gonna
be tough to pitch him in a movie yes I'm
going to say I'm Alexander on top of
that in the comic book Sam has this
great background he's from carefree
Arizona he's half Mexican half white and
so he brings this diversity that up to
this point other than Michael Pena
literally no no Latin X characters in
the MCU and this one would be a part of
it and have no ties to criminality which
would be great for media Marvel that
would be great you had your Black
Panther you can't just do a Mexican
Black Panther because everybody like
you're doing Mexican Black Panther to do
a Mexican American character who can
take us back into outer space he's
looking for his long-lost father Jesse
Alexander who was a part of the
supernovas group here's the bad guy look
at this awesome visual aid Titus this
cool I'm partial to 9 foot tall cat
creature so this is awesome you get this
mixed into it he's a character who in
his comic book iteration is visited by
Gamora and rocky raccoon we'll see what
happens with the MCU but he has these
ties to it he's bringing this youthful
energy he's bringing this perspective we
hasn't seen he gets to be the human
element kind of like star-lord Peter
quill we don't know what's gonna happen
after guardians 3 that can take us to
the MCU we get to experience more space
stuff maybe Galactus he's a friend of a
watcher which is great we've already
seen the Watchers and guardians vol 2 so
my pitch is gonna be Sam Alexander of
the Nova Corps they need more Nova's
they've been ravished by Ronan they've
been ravished by Thanos now apparently
so they're gonna be recruiting Sam
Alexander's my god thank you for
bringing visually it's Hector Navarro
Jacquelyn Coley I do agree with a lot of
the things that Hector said especially
about the fact that we need a space
centric Marvel movie unfortunately I
disagree with him because when we look
at the Marvel Cinematic Universe it is a
big wide sweeping landscape I do feel
like Nova is just a small corner of that
landscape and I do feel that story is
going to be again it'll be in your
neighborhood spider-man but your
neighborhood will be far far away I
think we have that already in the
spider-man series I don't think we
should bear off it yet the guy that I
think we should go with is a guy that's
already been teased but we haven't yet
seen him on screen and the thing I think
is more important to this question is
who's gonna anchor the Marvel MCU I
think the person for that is Adam
warlock it was teased at the end of
Marvel sorry it was teased at the end of
guardians vol 2 this is what the
sovereign was supposedly creating he's
this being that can't die well
able to bring in the mistresses aspects
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe he can
control energy its planetary I do feel
like this a character do I hate the fact
that I'm pitching you know quote unquote
another white male to be centered on the
MCU absolutely but we know it's casting
that isn't necessarily me that that we
we with the casting ends up the thing I
like about a most is the fact that magic
is magic when we're talking about it on
earth and its energy and cosmic
mysticism when we're talking about an
Asgard and he can kind of bridge that
gap between the two again I I love the
idea of bringing something young but
Adam warlock is the guy that can't die
I'm pitching the idea of doing an Adam
warlock movie along the lines of happy
deathday where we get to see him die and
come back literally can't die and then
we maybe get to see Lady Death
sorry also I forgot you know didn't we
hear that you know Xander got blown up I
don't know Nova is not the one I'm going
for it so I'm pitching Adam warlock all
right Thank You Jacqueline damn look
well my friends and colleagues raise
excellent points the future of the MCU
is female specifically Spider Woman
Jessica drew she is someone who has
connections to so many things that have
already they've laid the ground stones
for in the MCU she was a Hydra agent for
a while that she became a shield double
agent she went on to become over the
members of the New Avengers which seems
like a direction we're going to go and
considering we're missing quite a few of
them after infinity war spoiler alert
also she was an agent of sort which is
shield intergalactic arm that could
explain why perhaps we haven't seen her
in a while look spider-man does whatever
a spider can but Spider Woman goes above
and beyond that just by electric blasts
she is also she can I've traced out her
entire arc for this no I'm serious we
have the scrolls coming in with Captain
Marvel they are going to be the big bads
leading into a Secret Invasion movie and
in the comics Jessica drew was replaced
by a scrum in farang key and that is
going to be the ultimate reveal when
they built up this character he'd grow
to know and love who can grow on to
possibly lead the Avengers and then have
her turned heel like that it's gonna be
the ultimate betrayal there's a whole
arc here the other characters can play
along but honestly I don't care about
Sam Alexander fighting his inner force
onna
or Jesus Christ Superstar fanfiction
come to life on a son spider-woman wow
these three came to play mix it up a
listen Spider Woman is great this is
about the anchor and do you really think
that we're gonna agree agree agree is
about the anchor for the MCU that we're
gonna build it we're essentially saying
we're gonna have an
they're Iron Man that we're going to
then build off of yeah but does not need
to be someone who is like deep into that
Hydra shield place which we've already
very well explored through the Captain
America movies and everything else over
let's get to space everybody wants to
see more severe a United States of space
spider woman's been like Jaclyn saying
here's the other thing about Spider
Woman she's a great character and I want
to see her but to me look black widows
gonna get our own solo movie in the 80s
but Black Widow so far has been this
great presence in the Avengers movies is
kind of like a side player that's where
I think she is at her best the reason
that this big reveal when she turned out
to be a scroll after years wasn't the
most devastating in thing Evers because
in the comic books she was that side
character laced with our characters
there's a peel back to where you could
at least see a path to it don't though I
don't think that he Nova's in any better
anchor in all honesty over Adam warlock
at least with this one there's a path it
was already teased and guardians to
wheat sure pretty there's like so many
paths to get to I mean he supposedly
part of his essence is the soul gem so
like there it could be a whole part of
Avengers infinity for that we can go
directly into Adam warlock and there's
necessarily me know we'll talk about
fusing be a bad thing should be thrown
out along with the baby and the but for
this for Adam warlock to even work in
any capacity I feel like James Gunn is
gonna have to redo the character
completely it's really right and they're
already doing that but it's really tough
to argue against what the potentiality
of it could be my character has this
great basis this great foundation
already from the car books in the same
way that Iron Man was a solo specialist
I just can't picture easy on Lantern
being the anchor of the MCU go there's
another thing unfortunately I hate to
say it the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Marvel Studios is going to beat Warner
Brothers before they give us a Green
Lantern Corps movie that we deserve this
is the Marvel version of that similar
story and later Nova becomes a member of
the Avengers and then after that the
champions he is now a lot of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that we've seen
nothing about that's not true the Nova
cores already been introduced in
guardians 1 but they've been messed up
not the Nova Corps that you're talking
about actually about a different
timeline the super Nova's which is
essentially
yeah it's essentially hey you know that
thing do we introduce with Glenn Close
was in charge of well they're really low
on numbers so we needed some humans so
we got this guy the father of which I
say you know what make Jesse Alexander
played by a Poe Dameron everybody's
favorite actor in the entire word ask ur
Isaac and this guy should be played by
Anthony Isaac who voiced the lead
character in Coco get that Disney buddy
going this two guys can can be the
foundation and so many things have
already been introduced all I think it
will say on the last part of it is both
weird stories which I think are great
and I would love to see these movies I
still think they're soul movie the thing
about Adam warlock is there's elements
of the MCU that we have not seen that
his character can really bridge with
drop Wow
what a collision damn talk to us
anything on the facts side and and then
chime in with your judgment I mean
factually pretty clean other than the
fact that the fighting Galactus would
have of course be contingent on a fox
deal going support character currently
really isn't that just listen to the
passion you know these guys know more
about than I do don't even know they
could have made this was a really
difficult thing for a while Dan was kind
of swaying me towards Spider Woman but
ultimately I think that Jacqueline
actually won me over when she mentioned
happy deathday and the and the idea of
how you can do a superhero movie
differently and using the Adam warlock
in that way and that just kind of speaks
to my sensibilities and that was the art
that won me over snow gold with Jack
boom 104 Jacqueline Danielle Radford I
have you know the the thing that
Jacqueline said about happy happy
deathday did really get me Dan did have
great arguments however unfortunately
what I think he thought was a - was a
plus the idea of team Lantern that is a
dope movie and I want to see it and it
actually helped Hector who also had a
lot of really good very strong casting
ideas are really well fleshed out I
thought this is a movie that Hector has
thought about for like three years with
Hector okay you know what for all the
reasons that Danielle just said I also
gotta go with heck
[Applause]
[Music]
three all have serious ever planned for
that argument but there's just on
more like we're working then I heard
Jacqueline's question I was like thanks
for being here y'all you know what
Hector takes it all the nerd cred let's
check in with Ross Spencer and Joe out
there at the party what up y'all you are
killing it how this is a great night
thank you guys for sticking with us
remember we have puppets coming up later
but first I want to talk to these two
gentlemen right here mr. Spencer Gilbert
mr. Joestar at the very start of all of
this one amazing woman made a dream of
mine come true she purchased our
top-tier reward to choose any honest
trailer of her choice and she went with
all of Doctor Who so I want to check in
on how we're doing with that with some
fans submitted questions perhaps I am
the fan who is Doctor Who Oh doctor who
is a British wizard with a magical
girlfriend right and they travel they
make crank calls in an old phone booth
and go on adventures and I think they
fight like talking vacuum cleaners I'm
not as know they fight a Donald Dalek
yes I would like to know what a TARDIS
is and if that you cannot say that on
the internet that is not cool anymore
absolutely inappropriate
why don't you blink oh well if you if
you blink then the doctor changes into a
more charming British usually a guy
until recently Laura I don't want you to
worry because we've got this handled
we are gonna come in with the smartest
bestest most wonderful doctor who has
experts to school these gentlemen and by
the end of it they are gonna be riding
that TARDIS all the way around the
time.he why me universe now does a
promise from me to you there are 27 days
27 days of footage for you guys to watch
what's the plan
Wingardium Leviosa
never seeing our family again beautiful
thank you guys again for tuning on for
from making this possible at all we
could not have done this without our
amazing fans we could not have done this
without you Laura and we could not have
done this without Jared Quinn Matt
Chapman and Jonas Anderson mr. Anderson
thank you thank you thank you you just
contributed live you can keep
contributing at screen junkies dot-com
backslash charity event capital C
capital e do it do it do it back to you
all right guys I am sitting here with
the next speed round gauntlet fighters
and this is an assassin's row this is a
murderers row start we have some fan
favorites we've got some spray
up-and-comers who here do you feel the
most intimidated to fight mat key
because you are a dangerous dangerous
man on TV fights maybe but on movie
fights where I'm not prepared at all
like I'm a debater I'm a one of the
questions oh I can sit down and study
this and okay a counterpoint point like
I can do that off-the-cuff movie if I'm
gonna lose in the first round like I'm
gonna go down in a blaze of glory how
much I'm gonna lose well if we know
somebody's gonna lose that's just the
way of the game but you know who almost
never loses a superhero so if he if
there was a superhero who is fighting
movie fight who would win and who would
they take down oh man
I think you know I'm gonna say it's
superhero sorry I opened up the whole
whole box I think it'd be like you know
Tony Stark cuz he has the brains but he
also has the charisma it takes a lot of
charisma you got to use that charisma
sometimes and I said charisma enough I
don't know see this is like a test fight
this is a practice site okay coy you are
also incredible at specifically the
speed round what makes you good how do
you think you're gonna have the key to
victory to take down all these other
fools well I like to hold the mic
crazily which really helps the
formatting and also I always train with
some tech9 some Eminem some yellow wolf
some Machine Gun Kelly on the way
so I raffle long to get my vocal cords
ready and
then I also like to structure everything
in a three-act structures my arguments
are sound whilst being speedy and it's
the only place I can talk fast actually
get to use it so incredibly with it I
feel like all right I always slow down
in the world but not here Amy I saw look
on your face was that fear was that was
that you just getting game ready how are
you feeling right now it's a mixture of
awe and being like I'm taking notes I
didn't recognize any of the names of
those bands but bands named Machine Gun
Kelly for five notes so hopefully I can
rise whatever this challenge whatever it
is they're gonna ask us is there any
question that you do not want when do
you already making faces anything about
the Oscars that my brain does not have
the memory to contain all that all right
well we're gonna throw this over now
speaking of people who have a ton of
knowledge contained in their big brains
we're about to see a family torn asunder
but it's all for a great cause
and keep in mind you guys can keep
donating please please please women in
film is such an incredible organization
give them your money come on
but before you give them their money
watch this fight with the classiest lady
in the house its Alicia below with a
classic movie fight
well if you build it we will come
welcome to a very special round of
classic film fights
I'm Alicia Malone and I want to say
thank you to everyone for all your
donations your contributions we've all
been blown away by how much you've
supported women in film and it's so
important so thank you so much and we
have a pretty bumpy night ahead of us so
you might want to put on your seat belts
because we are battling
father-and-daughter
so we have you know it's the pictures
that got small he's still big you know I
mean he's so big actually that he has
his own day here in Los Angeles it is
the esteemed film critic mr. Leonard
Maltin
and she's ready for her close-up mr.
DeMille she's the co-host on Malton on
movies Jessie Moulton and because I
always depend on the kindness of
strangers
over there we have Mr Dan Morrill doing
facts and chicken and death and right
next to him Rothko net is stepping in as
another judge hey you know it's gonna be
the easiest fact checker yeah we have
the insight question the question today
is who is the greatest femme fatale Oh
how are you guys feeling about the
fighter you ready well here's the thing
we fight at home all the time
like that's that's no fun nah why would
I want to fight well I don't want to
embarrass him don't once yes why I think
that maybe you should battle mad battle
mr. Leonard Maltin Yuri okay come on you
guys
[Applause]
/ I retired from fighting no I know but
think of the children the tiny tots if
not now yes yes the tiny tots at home
Alisha you have to alright what do you
think I'm not saying you should be
intimidated daddy I would never say that
but mine is a women in film day anything
to see the return of the red fury there
we go
in black and white in color let's hear
your answer Leonard best femme fatale of
all time Barbara Stanwyck is fill extend
Rickson in double indemnity very tough
to be Alicia
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go with a film
that I just saw recently again leave her
to heaven
Ellen Brent played by Jane teeny in
glory in glorious Technicolor yeah these
are very interesting and wonderful
choices Leonard let's hear from you
first
well of course Stanwyck is a great
actress and she could do anything she
could do high drama she could do comedy
and everything in between but here she's
playing apart she's playing a character
who is literally a femme fatale because
death is involved murder is involved in
this story and who wrote it Raymond
Chandler and Billy Wilder you know you
don't get a better pedigree than that
apparently they hated each other and
didn't get along at all - two men two
writers and while they're also directed
but the results I mean the proof is in
the pudding
they turned out a terrific script a
terrific movie and it's only Wilders I
think third or so directorial endeavor
but the minute he sets her up the minute
you see her he it's a great reveal when
she comes down the steps of the winding
steps of her home and Fred MacMurray is
he can't keep he can't but poker face
doesn't work here he is smitten clearly
though he's there on an insurance case
and he's supposed to be professional
that goes out the window pretty quickly
and she is not I wouldn't call it a
subtle role or subtle performance but
she's not campy she's not over-the-top
and she invariably Mary Perry throughout
the film there's one dialogue scene
anybody who's seen the movie will
remember it where it's just snap crack
pop pop dialogue just unbeatable and
she's wearing a blonde wig which is very
odd but works everything works in this
film that is a compelling very tough
delecia look away from my childhood hero
right now I'm so and leave it I have
then as you mentioned Leonard it's a
Technicolor film noir and it's so
unnerving and quite surreal and
dreamlike to see all these dark
happenings these murders happen in broad
daylight and beautiful color and I feel
like that also mirrors the character of
Ellen because she is gorgeous she's very
glossy she comes from in a middle-class
family and but she's a fatal woman she's
very dangerous and she kills anyone who
gets in her way
and the thing that I find compelling
about her is that she as it says in the
film it's she loves too much so she's
not motivated by money or power it's by
love and you mean she is so fascinating
as a character because she falls in love
with Richard because he reminds her of
her father very of daddy issues there's
you could so much to delve into
psychologically and then she will kill
anyone no matter how sweet or innocent
or helpless they are if they threaten to
divert Richards attention away from her
so I think so often in movies women are
allowed to be only shades of extreme
they're good or they're evil they're
very stereotypical but here you have so
much going on simultaneously you see
underneath thanks to Jim tinis
understated performance that she
is ruthless but she also has a sense of
vulnerability underneath you see and her
big eyes that go glossy with tears so
there's a weird way that you feel for
her at the same time that you're
terrified of her
leave it to Alicia Malone to come out
what seemed like an unbeatable fight I
am torn I'm asked one quick follow-up
for you both how do you think each of
your characters and Leonard I clearly be
able to speak to this has impacted
cinema in terms of how we both perceive
and depict women
well Double Indemnity came at the very
beginning of what we now call the film
noir genre it wasn't called that then
they were called hard-boiled melodramas
there are other kind of names they had
for what later you know became film noir
so she's pretty early in the game I mean
maybe maybe Mary asked her in The
Maltese Falcon precedes her and a couple
of others perhaps but she's been
imitated ripped off and usually would
only moderate if any success because
Stanwyck just gives it a hundred percent
she's playing this woman for all it's
worth and with this silly blonde wig
which which just sort of calls more
attention to her in a way in a funny
kind of a way so I think being a an
exemplar a femme fatale femme fatale ism
means that you're gonna be copied and
you know copies are never as good as the
original
all right Alicia well I think it's it's
still so shocking to see Jeanne teeny in
this role I mean she is a woman who
watches her husband's disabled brother
drown
doesn't do anything to say what a shame
such a saying and she just chillingly
watches him until she realized the
husband is there and then she puts on
the ruse of going to fight for him but I
think in terms of it being a complex
character a character that is is still
quite shocking for women to watch
there's one moment when she says she's
pregnant and she says she something like
she feels like she's a prisoner this
beast I think she calls her baby has
imprisoned her body and that's something
that sometimes women you know my friends
have been gone through pregnancies that
they terribly sick and they're really
excited for their baby but they're also
feel like they are a prisoner of their
own body and it's something that you
know often see in films or talk about in
films so she's just very complex woman
and I think you you fear for her you're
so fear of her and I think just as an
example of interesting female character
and especially a character that's not
just evil on one level she has so many
layers going on to her these are - can
she also sleeps in full makeup you know
but everybody did that people still do
that today these are two beautiful films
of you guys haven't seen them
those are your pitches to go see them
immediately they are gorgeous gorgeous
portraits of two very different women
both great cases I need help Jesse it's
it's hot see this is the the trickiest
thing about the classic movie fights is
it these films are classic for a reason
and for us talking to Alicia about
classic film the love is there and it is
a Sophie's Choice the qu h twos your
favorite anything you go help how can
you choose one these these have lived
for such a long time because of the
impact they have and continue to have
when you watch them again we were all
just at the TCM film festival and you're
sitting in a theater with people and
you're watching it as if it's new and it
affects people just like it did the
first time
so I don't know that is that is part of
my heart wants to go with my dad part of
my head wants to go with a pic I have to
go with my dad is on you let's hear the
facts both two great performances to
both Oscar nominated performances Double
Indemnity was Billy Wilder's third
English language film his fourth overall
he did a French film called bad seed
translated bad seed so love is green
there you go this is very difficult and
I you know it's it's kinda like Jesse
said there's a reason that these
performances have endured for so long
because they're both great and memorable
and part of film history the argument
that got to me though and then and then
when it's kind of put in the scale this
is kind of how I kind of framed
everything else which is that Alicia
made a great argument for her choice
which was a great femme fatale but you
know kind of what Leonard said why
imitate the best and you can be the best
and I think he made such a great
argument for barbara stanwyck the fatale
was involved you know and I have to go
with Leonard on this one all right
[Applause]
just say that's gonna be one of my
favorite fights of this event I am sure
my heart I honor and I respect and adore
and worship you later but my heart
actually went with the red fury on this
one with Alicia I thought she made a
great case for a very complicated merger
but it doesn't matter what I think
the two of us went to Leonard Leonard
thank you so much for being here thank
you for your support and Alicia
it means the world and we are honored to
have all three of you can I just add one
quick thing yes and savage and detour
Lana Turner and The Postman Always Rings
Twice
Peggy Cummins and gun-crazy Rhonda
Fleming and out of the past Joan Bennett
in Scarlett Street that's all I want to
say I love that you said all of those
things after those incredible words of
wisdom we're gonna hear from Nick Mundy
welcome back dogs hit it raw dog brought
dogs back well guys we're gonna it's
we're talking women to film well I want
to start it off with a director as a
film in theaters currently Lynne Ramsey
show she's say someone was talking about
women in film Oh grab the internet yeah
that's right it's me the personification
of the Internet just to catch people up
who have no idea what the show is as to
what this bit is that's mostly everybody
what's your problem with women in film I
have a very well-thought-out critique
and that is what about wait for it Menon
feel Internet
don't you realize that there are a lot
of men in film and what I like pushing
them out we just want to celebrate the
women in film really yeah it's a
predominantly male industry oh look at
us we got the show just from showing up
that's true this this is a predominantly
male variety act yeah so I don't know
man is that all you got
it's nice to see you've been really
lonely the last two years well that
makes sense yeah yeah I got really
excited when I heard you were coming
back so that I could hate you more like
sense did you like the last Jedi oh I
did and that's why I love what we're
doing right now cuz it's just a
collection of weird lore no one really
cares about all jammed and put into your
face and you didn't ask for it
I'm with the Internet of this one
actually yeah we rarely agree but III
agree with the Internet all right well
we're gonna oh yeah by the internet go
back to writing honest trailers take me
with you
Monday Night Raw on a Thursday for one
night only that's how we do it here at
screen junkies and I'm here with your TV
fighters coming up next you guys we've
been talking a lot about women in film I
want to know who is the best woman on TV
yell Mariska Hargitay from SVU obviously
that is obvious answer she doesn't even
have to fight it Stacy what you got oh
gosh I mean I have to go with like a lip
oh yeah go with strong women in suits
gotta have a nice suit crisp suit oh she
actually threw in a fact yeah Michelle
I'm taking Tandy Newton in Westworld
oh and also rocking a Westworld madam
outfit interesting now we have our drunk
movie fights
up sober how do you feel about going
into this fight who do you thinks gonna
be a competitor have you felt about this
evening in general I've uh I've known
Stacy for a very long time she is as her
nickname sometimes this sassy Stacy
Howard yell is a fighter may have
murdered three people at some point
during a movie but I've been working
with Boyd for a long time and she has
studied the Queen herself Cersei
Lannister
I trust she'll find a way to win ah this
is tough tough fight I have to say
though we're coming up on the speed
round gauntlet and the speed round is a
killer
what is the key to winning a speed round
but speaking and not stopping that's
what it is because something will come
out of your mouth and it will be a
sentence and it will make sense at some
point just like I'm doing now I have not
thought about it but I'm saying words
there you go you're a pig
well before we get into the fight if the
good people want to find you if the good
people want to shout out because your
answers are wrong where can they find
you guys I'm everywhere at yell Tegel I
am at Stacey o Howard no Ino I just why
I don't know if I looked at the right
camera I'm at Michele Boyd mich ele b
oid and you guys remember you can keep
donating to this incredible cause you
can support these women tweet at us get
into the women in film charity and of
course just keep being part of this
event which were all so excited to be
doing we're so proud of and equally
proud I've got Roxie stryer sitting on
the desk ready to throw down another
gauntlet getting me so excited for this
speed around gauntlet you guys know
we're on right now let's work when you
snap oh wait that's the wrong gauntlet I
even got it written for me by lon oh and
you guys butchered it let's get into
this though you guys know for sure
that's what I that's what I do man you
blew it you blew it so hard
you guys have 20 seconds each to fight
something and ten seconds - ah but
you've done this before
been here done this if you want away
with us today yeah how's it going
everybody it's your boy just hold
seriously big muscles leave right not
even gonna lie I'm a key of course yeah
yeah of course that's fine you didn't
even want to throw them up you do want
to show off your muscles next to soup
amazing people coming up after you guys
I doubt either of you makes it to the
end but maybe you'll prove me wrong
let's go into it I actually don't even
know where my speed round questions are
they're smoking on cards somewhere I
heard that they're gonna be popping up
just where with the first speed round
question as they come up on the cards
from what I was
oh oh oh okay
yep here we go with the first bead
around from a donator thank you so much
JC Jones here is the question
what is the best Kurt Russell movie of
all time from the audience I escaped
from LA okay look man escape from LA is
that 90's movie cuz it has everything
you want you know dude in an eyepatch
long hair leather jacked up and ready to
get jacked up also surprisingly
progressive for its time it had a trans
character it was they never made fun of
her of her pronouns or anything they
actually addressed her as a superior I
said picture all a little shiner right
okay a little Chyna
he's a truck driver this is this is Kurt
Russell at his best he's grizzled he's
hairy he's wearing a tank top the whole
time just to show off them Kurt Russell
muscles the Russell's from muscles
that's what are the muscles from Russell
I think is his nickname I don't know go
in it and he's fighting ninjas and
they're they're in Little China it's
amazing
that's tight but he had no leather pants
in big trouble at in China yeah a
hundred percent did in escape from LA
and those pants was shiny and he was
even getting wet at the beginning he was
underwater
you got wetness while he had mother
pants which is great he was wearing a
tank top and he did drive a semi and
Kurt Russell in a semi with a the CB
like this is a Kurt Russell
come on oh gosh I feel like we spend a
lot of time talking about leather and
this last one and being wet which made
me uncomfortable I think though what I
heard more about was not just Kurt
Russell in the movie like which is the
best Kurt Russell but which is the best
Kurt Russell movie and that was from you
Effie Effie you get the point on this
one and therefore you will be staying
through to this next round which will be
against Wendy Lee zany go get some
cheese that's our cue to get the cheese
yeah get outta wendy's way and cut right
across that camera yeah Wendy here we go
with this next round if you ready when
are you ready I'm not ready but I am at
the same time here we go don't know what
to do with that one so I'm just gonna
keep on barreling through this one is
from the donator door auntie rose thank
you so much other than Gollum who is the
best evil character in The Lord of the
Rings films other than Gollum gonna call
that eye of Sauron I'm going to I am
going to say I can't remember his name
but it's the steward we can we can
accept it okay we'll work with that huh
we'll work with that alright that a yes
from the team thank you
all right so have you ever been taking a
dump in a public restroom and then
you're looking through the slit and
you're like if somebody stared at me and
it freaks you out that's what the higher
siren is just through the whole movies
just he's just peeping you like it feels
like somebody's watching me and someone
is it's the Eye of Sauron also it's on
fire - so you just sitting there not
only are you afraid but you're wondering
does he need an eye drop or something
because maybe that would make him less
evil so Denethor is just mentally
unstable killing one of his own family
members because that's what he thought
was right no matter what it is
he is just stopped believing in anything
that is relevant and all he saw was was
what he wanted my idea and never ever
ever I mean this is mental earth lots of
people are killing people killing family
members know what people aren't doing
peeking sneaking looking at other people
and that's creepy because that's not
doing that you know who's doing it is
all wrong
very weird doesn't do anything he stands
on the top of a tower and just moves
this big creeper red I think around and
does nothing Denethor physically put a
family member still alive on a pile of
wood to burn to death that is pure evil
well I'm hearing some Sasha woo-woo-woo
damn that time that comeback was really
strong but what I will say is that the
question is best evil character not most
evil character and while I do feel like
when do you describe more evil things if
he I think you described the best evil
characters energy you're getting this
one - you're staying at the table Wendy
great jug this chair I think I'm like
that she pretty warm oh you want to swap
we're really swapping chair
so here we go guys this question is
coming from a Christo wrister with um
yeah Krista she says if you are planning
a party where you and your friends are
going to marathon and entire film
franchise which she's qualifying is
something that is at least eight hours
long what would be the best marathon
Marvel Cinematic Universe the host of
Marvel movie news fighting that shocker
alright the Halloween franchise okay
okay whenever you are ready okay cuz my
party is gonna be a bachelorette week
and that's gonna start with all the
thirst traps that you get in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we're gonna start off
with Ironman obviously because 2008
we're gonna bring that back when it
started off 2008 themed with Ironman and
work our way progressively through
changing our outfits as we're drinking
working through Ironman we have Thor
we're gonna do Thor dark world we're
gonna do that one on weed though because
it's gonna we're gonna keep that high
and we're gonna hit Thor Ragnarok all
that thirst
powering through and then I will have
infinity war for my girls because we're
going to complete that book and all of
our Thurston's in in-between and action
all the way through do I say have more
time along with that
and ruins one job okay so so my part is
actually gonna be a spooky Dookie party
where everybody dress up like the
babadook and we watch Halloween and so
like for that movie you know we want to
get in but really what we're making our
way to is Halloween h2o because I got my
man Busta Rhymes in it I loved the MCU
but it's missing something bus a bus and
where we gonna get Halloween h2o if bus
a bus was in the movie if bus a bus was
in the MCU it will probably be a
complete franchise like the Halloween
franchise something amazing about the
MCU and having that as a parties that
it's actually gonna make sense as it
goes through as opposed to Halloween
when you have to keep on going back keep
on going back and they killed Jamie Lee
Curtis and I'm not about that and that
is not a party that is a funeral about
this calmly makes sense because it's the
same antagonist throughout all the
movies Marvel MCU people are gonna be
like why does dark world suck why does
he you know like people are gonna be
following in theirs like oh man Doctor
Strange is droopy a lot of a lot of
fighting words in this one I first of
all I want to let you guys know that I
learned where thirst trap was this week
so I'm really happy I'm really feeling
the edge here second of all I think that
while there was a little shade thrown at
the MCU saying that some of the movies
like dark world maybe people wouldn't
like they definitely would make sense in
this marathon I think the argument for
it you just painted a fun party and
that's what this was about you painted a
great marathon so is this seat coming in
we're gonna do another seat change or
are we feeling good now just hitting the
gunner time that microphone goes back
down I'll gladly sit there no it's gotta
stay up there here we go this next
question from Charles Leigh Thank You
Charles
which movie is more fun to rewatch Tron
or Tron Legacy Tron Tron Legacy that
would be the only other answer yes Merc
you and ever you ready
enough cannot be said about how
incredibly fun it is to do a revisit
back to Chon because that you can also
like theme that around your day kind of
a thing like you can do like an Ultimate
Frisbee thing like during the day
portion because Tron would be at night
and then along with that you can you
have that styled out where and really
awesome about Tron is that there is
enough practical effect balance next to
CGI as opposed to Trump okay so this
question isn't about which movie is
gonna be more likely to be remembered or
which movies considered more of a
classic it's about which one is more fun
to re-watch and Tron Legacy is a big
Technicolor party which is really fun to
revisit amazing soundtrack you could I
was listening to your party question you
could theme it and be like today is the
psycho combat day today at the nightclub
day today is the what's really great
about the rewatch with tron is that
particular like car driving one where
you're like whatever and then they like
do that with the smash thing and then
Tron Legacy they kind of missed the mark
on that and that really really
frustrated me as a viewer so I wouldn't
want to re-watch that okay but you can
show off the tricks that are unique to
turn legacy the use of 3d comparable to
Wizard of Oz where they're using all of
the tricks at their disposal you can
find new things in it and it's just sort
of a good time movie as opposed to an
all-time classic oh gosh this amazing
question first of all Charles really put
our fighters to the test here so great
job both of you guys I have to say based
off of these arguments I'm not 1000%
convinced that amy has seen either maybe
maybe you know maybe you Adam or King
specifics and yours was more general
working at the point on this one Amy you
fought your best though Amy you are
moving out of that seat that is getting
colder and colder a lot of hair is
coming in to see if he can
[Applause]
all right thank you why are we squealing
that's apparently the noise that I make
when movie fighting I make a spooky
high-pitched squeak so let's move on
from that cuz I'm about ready David
Morris thank you David wants to know
which film character would you want to
fight for you in a dance-off battle
sorry Lord
Nomi Malone from showgirls she's not
okay but is murky we're starting with
you okay the reason I chose Peter quill
because not only is he an ultimate
dance-off champion he his dance-off
skills are so strong that he was able to
distract Ronan the accuser from smashing
the Power Stone into the surface of
Xander when he was one step away from
winning Peter Quill's dance moves and
that dance-off just brought that and I'm
sorry Nomi Malone doesn't have those
dance skills because it's definitely not
you could already tell star-lord is
intentionally a comic dancers doing it
to distract these don't get to be silly
Nomi Malone is 100% invested in that
performance it's not ironic it's not
cute she's giving her wonder because it
may look strange to those of us who are
not Vegas showgirls ourselves but that
is 100% her and her performance and her
truth coming out through dances that's
what I went defending me it's proven
cinematically that Peter quill was not
dancing ironically he was dancing for
the fate of Xander and then the fate of
other planets that were in there while
Naomi was dancing for the fate of her
next line of coke and
it's horrible it's all to show me Malone
he has a little drug problem oh no we
hold that against her in terms of
representing me in the dancer and their
boobs being silly he's being funny it's
a distraction move it's not who's the
greatest dancers nothing Black Swan he's
trying to distract her on it ah I don't
know if I'm getting just swayed by the
cheers & boos of the audience but I will
say that the invested part of it did get
me more and the end line not being a
better dancer it's not the point it's
who is really gonna give it their all
and are we sure that star-lord is gonna
be invested in fighting for you we don't
know lon you're taking this one I was
gonna say star-lord I don't know how
that just happened I really don't know
the final fight though will be between
between Lana and coy John Doe you should
not be the person we elect to do the
dance-off for what you're trying to say
I don't even give you a second to stick
because we're getting right into this
with Sam Purcell thank you Sam
the question is what is the best sequel
that changed genres slash tone from the
movie before aliens
Oh gremlins - new batch koi whenever you
are ready
alien was a fantastic horror film aliens
made an action genre that is new and
complete to itself that was a sci-fi
action movie showed us what James
Cameron do it showed us what the genre
can become and it allowed the movie to
turn into an entirely new genre while
building on the pre established notions
of the film it didn't get to stare the
criteria didn't get any of the rules but
it built upon and it allowed us to be
bigger and more that's always supposed
to do but in that new genre I was able
to bigger and more and add more aliens
while not sacrificing the person with
integrity
the original gremlins is a great sort of
horror with a little bit of like a
comical satirical tone it's really very
dark and it's Sensibility but the genius
of gremlins 2 is it takes the same
concept to the same world do same
characters and it turns it into this
absurdist cartoon over-the-top sort of
hyper reality that's really one of the
only films in it's sort of respective
genre it's this really heightened
larger-than-life really absurd comedy
aliens who gave us you gremlins -
gave us lots a little funny hygienic
scrambling to is mattre memorable it's
remember being a comedy it's light its
fluffy aliens - is one gave us James
Cameron's alien - that's such a
different movie and it did in the game
the gremlins - negated the first one
alien and aliens are really not very
different in terms of the genre there's
more action in the second there's more
aliens but really it's still it's a
sci-fi movie it's a horror movie we're
really in the same world they're
functionally very similar plot wise
they're extremely similar
ah that's noise that I make oh gosh this
is such a good one interesting point at
the end there lon about whether is or is
not in a different genre but I feel like
we did a great job fighting that it was
even though he couldn't come back at
that I think that his fight was just
stronger COI he got in more words which
is one of your tactics
[Applause]
debride breathing is overrated gosh geez
we're gonna throw this now
congratulations to coy to the balcony as
they are hanging out we're going to come
back here with some long-awaited TV
[Music]
what's up party people having fun out
there one big part of your generous
donations means that you have unlocked
the bail that's right we're bringing
back the belt but it is at this point
been vacated so let me break down who is
going to win and how the belt is on the
line today but we don't know which fight
it's gonna be who's gonna be the champ
we're gonna have a new one coming out of
today's fight who will be challenging
them is one of these gentlemen plus coy
I believe who just won that all right
Coyle be comin out in a second so the
winner the winner of the speed gauntlet
and Monday what are you doing here
just havin a cold one okay fair enough
so what if one of these gentlemen II D
Joe or coy will be joining Dan and i's
the only people lucky enough to have
touched this magical object it will be
determined in the coming weeks ed you
have any words for europe just get ready
for these uh seventeen and a half inch
pythons to come down on you good good
I'm just excited that we could have a
real puppet as a champion instead of our
two previous puppet champions Dan how's
it feel to be a bitter like me that we
don't have this anymore I mean I've had
months to live with it now so it's just
a part of me
the sadness has become a part of them
yes that's all from here I'd like to
thank some donors who've come in during
the show Billy Paula Han what's up man
thank you so much grace Nixon thank you
so much
Cody Hoyt you're doing it guys you're
doing it and you know who else is doing
it Roxy for an upcoming TV fights back
to your oxy
[Applause]
nothing better than us being delayed
like that holy crap has it been a minute
since we've been here and if you were
wondering if Lucille has changed it
looks the same to me no they threw away
my old bat it was a big issue in fine
but let's come back with some of our
most amazing fighters the people who
have earned their spot at this table for
the TV fights come back and might I
mention it is all women in very elegant
of you yeah I'm ready to throw down so I
thought I'd start off polite okay okay
Stacy Howard hey I'm not elegance at all
what's up guys follow these lovely women
oh right by destroying them by smashing
them to legitimate smithereens those
little tiny bits and here to help us
judge who smashes the most is of course
oh my gosh hi captain
hey Roxy back he came back and he's
sitting there and I'm looking at him
it's great old times
Billy stole my hair from when I was here
a little bit I keep the food box outfit
today the pony you were doing the pony
more he's now got the such a different
vibe afterwards but now we are gonna get
into this unbelievable fight are you
guys ready yes yes I never want it to
end what was the best TV series of 2017
that is the question yell we are
starting with you and making our way
around the table the answer is of course
The Handmaid's Tale you may have
forgotten Roxy but I just say the name
alright your mic drop kind of gal Stacy
what a guy oh my gosh okay well I just
want to say looking at the television
series options for 2017 I was really
excited and proud of the female driven
stories we were presented with but you
know what I gotta go with glow that's
right you guys the gorgeous ladies of
wrestling for the other choices we had
today my fight was I mean it's hard to
go against them but I picked that
because it transcends going for a
specific genre or targeted audiences and
can really appeal to everyone when you
talk about TV series appealing to
everyone you're gonna have to go with my
choice and I was actually a little bit
lucky with mine because unlike these
other two series who are in their
infancy mine had three series beforehand
to kind of prove its worth and is in
series for Black Mirror I mean really
this kind of series it just transcends
everything it goes from comedy it goes
from sci-fi it goes to horror and it
just kind of all encompasses it's such a
great show and it was my favorite for
2017 alright now crush each other Black
Mirror yes it has these different
elements but this season from 2017
season was one of the most highly
anticipated seasons and one of the most
disappointing seasons the episodes were
mismatched
and the vibe was wrong and it felt like
they show it has already jumped the
shark talking about I'm gonna get jump
in here because first of all that
three-bath does the Hugo Award and the
Saturn Award it's already been nominated
for and or one kind of already proves
you wrong and personally I'm waiting for
the 2018 Emmys because guaranteed is
just gonna jump and keep going even more
than it did back in the 2007 if you're
talking about it being disjointed they
had an entire thing in the very last
episode of black Museum where they're
showing all of these different aspects
from the other episodes proving that it
can really be one of the same universe
they had the DNA scanner from USS
McAlister there the Archangel tablet
they had a bathtub from crocodile it
really proved that it was an overarching
series it wasn't just like standalone
little episode let's forget about these
two Downers for a second and talk about
the upper that is glow an injection of
fun you guys I mean you've got
everything in the serious comedy drama a
little action in their eighties
nostalgia which is very on-trend right
now and it has beautiful relationships
very dynamic between all the women
you've got friendships you've got
betrayal you've got very serious issues
like adultery and abortion being touched
on you got Marc Maron the you know dad
of the series he's like the distant dad
I never had that I really wanted in my
life being like hey what if we had a
fight that ended in an abortion if he
great on the first of all Awards let's
talk about that for a second the Emmy
for training Johnson's lead actress
Elisabeth Moss Supporting Actress
writing directing guest star of Alexis
Bledel
so Awards yeah sorry we won but there's
more talking actors we can talk Jodie
Foster being an oscar-winning actress
directing one of the episodes and
Letitia right now jumping into black
panther and is just loving my life right
now so like I The Handmaid's Tale is one
of the most relevant shows are
horrifying jokes relevant and a
cautionary tale
it is something that we can all watch
and go oh crap this might be happening
maybe we should do something
maybe we should wake up and say
something and the acting is outstanding
on it
they've won Outstanding Lead Actress
it's an amazing show it's relevant and
it doesn't need to transcend audiences
audiences are watching because they want
to they want to see it they want to know
what's happening and this season of the
second season was super exciting for
everyone was ready for it to come back
and it came back and they're happy
whereas Black Mirror last season people
were like what this show's done we're
done oh I'm sorry no one who watched USS
Macau USS Callister said that the show
is done it was had been what is the most
fun series of 2017 I would give it to
you but it's not it's G Series are a
great cautionary tale as you said about
what could happen but globally basically
all characters a real show that happened
and it is still inherently interesting
so that's a lot more difficult to take a
true story and true people that existed
we already know what happened to that
show we already know what half of those
characters there's a documentary about
it but we still wanted to watch that
story and see what goes on but you guys
this is just a cautionary tale and I'm
just like shocked and heartbroken at the
end and it's such a downer I want to be
uplifted I want inspiring stories I'm
not lifting all you really have to do is
watch hang the DJ it's such an adorable
romantic comedy between the two and
you're really fighting for this couple
the entire time and it actually leads
toward a dating app that I would
personally want to use that actually
matches you with someone that you've
already gone through a thousand
different iterations with over the -
over the internet I don't know what it
is that you guys are looking for at a
show but what I was looking for - it's
not depressing the entire time it is not
fun the entire time but you actually get
to experience both within it remember
when the mom is stuck in the bear that's
so fun I love that I love that
The Handmaid's Tale gives you a show
that yes it is a cautionary tale yes it
is incredibly relevant but it is also a
show that is interesting to watch you
don't know what's gonna happen it is
terrifying and exciting you're on the
edge of your seat and you're invested in
these characters you cry watching this
show I don't know anyone who's cried
watching
I'm cried watching that eighty is the
blush going I call on me remix and it
was really just a music video from ten
years ago oh dang besides just the
performances because we keep harping on
that and also like what makes you cry
why is your show the standalone best
show what makes it better because we're
describing the same thing better
performance makes me cry more or less
what makes it the best mine's more
well-rounded than the other two shows
those are very specific genres that only
like a niche audience might enjoy but
mine is all ages all genders people that
enjoy all kinds of different kinds of
films and television everything is
encompassed and glow with that
personally I feel like as far as when
she's talking about Handmaid's Tale
being something that might come to pass
black mayor to me is always something
that is a lot more immediate when you're
talking about things that might come to
pass because we're talking about
everything from AI we're talking about
dating apps we're talking about just the
Internet in general social media queues
hashtags being like drones coming after
people like these are real and immediate
things that actually could happen and
are actual questions that we kind of
have to start thinking about just as a
society moving forward like who really
do we want to be Handmaid's Tale while
very compelling and a really good story
like I'm sorry I see is just much
farther off no not really don't we
really don't have like a fertility
crisis impending yet so I disagree that
glow is is the one show that everyone's
watching and all the other shows are
niche I don't know many people that are
watching glow compared to black mirror
and Handmaid's Tale but also when it
comes to black mirror I think that up
until literally the last season it was
great this last season it knocks it off
and it is not the best of 2017 wasn't
possibly the worst handmade steel was a
new show this season it came out and it
was just draw dropping everyone I know
is talking about it everyone is watching
and they're making sure that they're not
missing an episode because they don't
want to be spoiled it's it's the game of
Thrones effect it's the west-world
effect it's the show everyone's watching
and everyone's talking about
alright based on these arguments based
on these arguments I want to go over to
my men over there Billie starting with
you what do you think yeah I think look
all great arguments all three of you
proving why some of the best fighters
that we have in the screen junkies
roster but for me I think Michelle was
able to take the best of yells and the
best of Stacey's and say hey my shows
got both of those so my point goes to
Michelle all right can where's your
point look I'm looking online here I got
people checking in using the hash tag
movies fights live I've got chicken
parmesan
we got Patricia Carillo saying now that
I'm home I can tweet again that's good
welcome to the show she has both of her
TV fights guys but in terms of the
actual show there are some good points
Zak arm burger says I like yells points
but I think she'd give up too much
ground already
Michelle was killing this round I do
like what Billy said here where I felt I
felt yell didn't address her show she
was just putting opinions into black
beer in first the ratings trying to do a
little bit of fact-checking which is
technically my job the tomatoes audience
scores are holding steady 93% and 83%
audience score though that is down about
8% from last season mmm
so where's your point though Ken cuz I'm
like before you where you didn't get
other than right now you're kind of now
you do I would second Billy and I got it
I gotta go with Boyd here so since they
both give it to me
you are the one that becomes the victor
I will say that I happen to agree with
my men on this one it did take the best
of both worlds and when they fought
against you saying that there was no fun
in it you threw back hang the DJ at them
so that is where it's at Michelle was a
very tough argument super tough
favorites are amazing it could be our
last TV fights moment a lot of people
were asking if this is canon I think
it's Elseworlds because I am wearing
King's hair in clothes
this counts it's Episode one hunt and
ask for another 100th episode if you
want congratulations Michelle on your
victory guys don't go anywhere because
we still have a ton of stuff including
this next thing we're hearing from a lot
of our favorite women in film here we
are talking about women in film why it's
an incredible organization but let's
talk about some of our actual favorite
women in film here are some of our most
beloved raddest baddest chicks the first
person that really inspired my passion
for film was my mother I used to watch
old movies with her all the time and she
would tell me Star Wars but then also
show me the films that inspired Star
Wars like Kurosawa and the serials that
inspired George Lucas but one of the
things that really struck me when we'd
be watching old films were Mae West and
Betty Davis these were women who were so
unabashedly confident and funny and
talented and themselves even still today
I would love to have one tenth not only
of their ability but just of their
Surefire and will to live there's a line
from a movie that my mom used to show me
called Auntie Mame which is life is a
banquet and most poor suckers are
starving to death
well these women were feasting every
second of their lives a female that very
much impacted me
when I saw her in film is angela bassett
strange days dealt with so many issues
and contained it all in a sci-fi
thriller movie it just it made a huge
impact for me to not only have someone
of angela bassett stature in a sci-fi
movie and I was such a sci-fi nerd but
along with that it had a very strong
message it was directed incredibly and I
feel like it stands the test of time
growing up I used to watch a ton of
reruns and I remember watching Laverne
and Shirley and being like that woman is
so great she's so funny she's so
interesting and one of my favorite
movies growing up was big and when I
found out that Penny Marshall was the
same person for both it blew my mind she
can be this insanely talented comedian
but she can also direct one of the best
comedies ever and that she was able to
produce that she was able to go across
all these different platforms the first
woman in film to inspire me was my
mother she was a film editor before I
was born and so I grew up hearing her
stories about working on set working in
production and she more than held her
own in this male-dominated world I'm
always gonna be grateful to her for the
film education she gave me for telling
me these stories of how it is possible
for a woman to excel in this field and
for supporting me in my dreams of being
part of the film industry I'll never
forget in 2003 when monster came out
being this little girl in Massachusetts
who had always wanted to be an actress
and watching Charlize Theron on screen
be this horrible hideous character that
was oscar-nominated that was just talked
about around town and having that be
unlike anything I had ever seen in terms
of female roles in movies then I
remember being a little older and
learning that patty Jenkins had directed
that film and thinking wow a woman
directing a woman in a movie that
actually doesn't happen that often now
flash forward many years later of course
patty Jenkins was directing gal gadot
and Wonder Woman how cool is that for
one woman to bring to light these
female stories that were so different
from each other but both deserve to be
told the first time I remember being
seen on screen was when I was about four
or five years old and I saw National
Velvet starring Elizabeth Taylor she
plays a jockey who wasn't allowed to
compete in the Grand National race
because she was a woman but she ends up
pretending to be a boy and wins the race
and that made me feel like I could do
anything and it also made me think
differently about gender politics and
how maybe that shouldn't necessarily
always hold you back for me one of the
biggest moments that happened was
recently it was with Black Panther there
are so many amazing women characters in
that movie from spies to soldiers to
generals to scientists to yes a
nurturing mom it's rare to see something
that represents me on screen and so to
get to have that with Black Panther
there's a reason why it's touched so
many people guys we've talked about a
bunch of movies that are directed or
featuring women today but there's
probably a bunch that maybe you don't
even know we're directed by women movies
that you love and I love we all love
like Wayne's World Pet Sematary Fast
Times at Ridgemont High American Psycho
the babadook children of a lesser God
look who's talking deep impact Billy
Madison Winter's Bone whale writer
Persepolis 13 boys don't cry zero dark
thirty Sleepless in Seattle
Punisher war zone lost in translation
disobedience clueless what would they
want bel a league of their own girl
fight Bend It Like Beckham The Kids Are
Alright
Selma We Need to Talk About Kevin and so
many more so thank you guys so much for
your support because this event all of
this it's just about you and me all of
us movie lovers getting more of what we
already love wow you know what we told
you this is the greatest crossover of
all time and it wouldn't be that without
the collider gang
[Applause]
harder wine Deeley we got mark ellis
dressed like my drunk uncle brave and
his toon squad shirt parry number off
thank you so much for being here
John Roca everyone who yes mark
Before we jump into some Collider movie
fights I just wanted to plug you got
some stand-up comedy coming up you're
gonna be a New York Comedy Club G 7th
and 8th I mean yes you get tickets at
Mark Ellis live.com can be casual and
Roca can dress like Joe Pesci right
after he gets made in Goodfellas shoot
me a head goddammit alright let's do
this here is the question for the
collider crew Oh on Don theme what two
franchises should collide what two
franchises should collide and we're
gonna start off with from the schmoes
know the cute one Mark Ellis I would say
franchises that should collide Denzel
Washington has a movie coming out later
this summer called the equalizer too and
I thought it might be a nice idea to
have that aging action star team up with
another aging action star so here's the
premise of the next movie in the
franchise the Denzel he likes going
after these young ladies that get
kidnapped and they get sold into sex
rings so some young lady gets kidnapped
he goes to Sabre and once you note
somebody else is going to save that
young lady why because that's Liam
Neeson's daughter from taken we're going
taken and we're going to equalizer
between the two of them ten Oscar
nominations two Oscar wins most of them
by Denzel but it still stands to reason
that you want to have a team-up of
action movies because the way that
action movies continue to build and
build steam with sequels is when you
have multiple stars in them you can only
be a lone wolf for so long how that's
why an equalizer in taken is gonna be
Baca Papo box office for both of them
that's like Lethal Weapon except they're
both getting too old for this
Perry alright so rather than take the
approach of this thing is the same as
this thing so make let's make this thing
same thing all over again
I want one franchise that's gonna shed
some new light on another franchise and
vice versa so that's why I'm going final
destination and
starwars well I love that death tripperz
book I want me a Star Wars horror movie
I love Star Wars I love horror and there
is something about the concept behind
the final destination movies and the
idea of death design that really could
speak to the idea of the force and using
the dark side of the force like Yoda
said once you go down that dark path
it's gonna consume you so I want a new
force user and I want that force user to
dabble in the dark side set off death
they have the premonition they come back
to they rescue a whole bunch of people
and then they go back in because death
is coming back around to get them again
cos they are consumed by it and they are
screwed and obviously with final
destination half the fun of that
franchise is the big meltdown that
happens at the beginning and look at all
the different landscapes you could have
some new fun you could have a Star
Destroyer crash you could go small and
set in a cantina and then there are so
many possibilities after that this guy
with her who who's teaching you about hi
anyone that's not another do with a
fight are you good Jon I see you took
advantage of the merchants boy
I appreciate those will all be up on
eBay after the show damn right John well
for me I love both of these choices I'm
not the biggest fans of them but I love
them I respect these guys but like for
me it is Matt Damon's Jason Bourne
combining with Daniel Craig's James Bond
that's the combination those two have
been incredible revolution in the spy
genre revolution these type of movies
bring them back to life make it a lot of
money at the box office yeah they don't
have a lot of Oscars between them but
they're respected and loved by the
public you put them together on a
mission maybe trying to find out what
actually happened to my man Jason Bourne
what actually I would like to go oh you
need to go behind the scenes of what who
is really James Bond who's Daniel
Craig's actual character we went to that
Scottish mansion whatever that was out
in the middle of nowhere in a swamp we
want to find out more these two on a
mission to figure out what their actual
real identities are and the audience's
will be gripped and they're fantastic
and those movies of those four movies
that they've done have made a lot of
money at the box office that this baffle
box office argument is already null and
void so we've got two incredible actors
who people want to go and see and it
would be fantastic plus Skyfall one of
the best James Bond movies ever made and
Bourne Ultimatum one of the best Bourne
movies ever made all right we got three
interesting combos fight it out y'all I
hope you have a hundred million dollars
to pay Daniel Craig because he already
said he doesn't want to come back and be
James Bond again went on the record to
say he's not gonna be in any Bourne
movie that has anybody else in and Matt
Damon wants to be the sole start where
Denzel Washington and Liam Neeson
haven't proven throughout their careers
they can team up in an insomuch that
when I was new to get to walkers for
both of them and a medic on site the
whole time it's ridiculous plus the the
taken movies have gotten worse and worse
and worse and your pitch is that once
again Liam nos lost his daughter once
again this daughter got taken same exact
thing happening all over again which is
why I kind of hit the snooze button when
I hear both of your pitches because what
I want in two franchises colliding is
something fresh and different I agree
with Roca because did you see the
commuter they can't cut around Liam
Neeson any more he is so slow with the
axe
to the well that he wants and you talk
about hitting the snooze button if I'm
lucasfilm that's hitting the panic
button because Lucasfilm has learned
from the last Jetta you do not mess with
cannon or else you're gonna piss off the
fans if you bring if you go Hart horror
r-rated Star Wars final destination is
the best possible idea cuz the whole
point is that debts design comes full
circle done and it doesn't affect
anything else what's this idea of horror
over there triangle rates call New
Mutants how many times have pushed that
back there's no logical sense of the run
horse franchise these ideas are
desperate but Lucasfilm and Star Wars is
the one that doesn't need the desperate
we don't need to team up with final
destination why that's like letting Rudy
play for the New England Patriots we
don't need to lend a hand right it's
gonna 68 year old man going back to a
franchise he's messed up already three
times you want I can have not close in
their loops in the same way the Daniel
Craig does not would it be James Bond
anymore Matt Damon has closed Damon also
tore apart the James Bond talk about
tearing apart the misogyny of a
character like that
this is ridiculous so what you've got
here Matt Damon is great fantastic in
the Jason Bourne movies he's excited
he's still young audiences still come to
see his stuff you've got you've got
Daniel Craig's James Bond coming back he
already said he's coming back so that
argument is mute he says he's gonna come
back and fight and do James Bond for
Danny Boyle 25 if you bring him back and
Jason Bourne then you've got it might
sign up for even more Bond movies
because you've got him something new
you've injected new life into the
franchise and that works final
destination makes no sense I don't want
to see Tontons
eating Jedi's every other they go they
go they opened the thing and then they
got a lightsaber in their face and died
the door on the horror franchise until
he sees something that he likes because
it's a little different argument than no
one knows yeah well it isn't it's an
argument that you've already made
cleared sitting at this table anything
related to the horror genre he'll shoot
down no matter what
that is the whole point of growing
branches is tapping into new things look
at what we're constantly talking about
with marvel how they're trying different
things with Winter Soldier and all and
different things with Congress that's
the point that Star Wars is gonna hit is
that eventually they're gonna need to
branch out and try new things no matter
what to keep the franchise going
they found success with it in the death
trooper book there is so much fun ideas
to explore that one fit within the rules
of the Star Wars film franchise but to
appeal to the horror genre and you know
what that brings a whole nother audience
into that franchise but my things are
already vibrant horror the final
destination is a done franchise nice
Star Wars is on its ropes movies to get
it right in your two franchises a done
character the Dino Chris no longer wants
to play he's gonna do it for Danny Boy
Alex and then the guy is I already said
he's coming for Danny Boyle 25 and he's
going to stay if they do a good movie
and that's what's really important and
both these guys are vibrant they're
actually happening right now
Wow Wow is that the septage anarion ziz
a final destination a Star Wars story or
BB born in bond let's go to Christian
Over Law well I do want to say that the
fans are given a lot of great
suggestions here the ami awesome said
the Fast & Furious franchise and cars
would be a project that events says that
John wick and the Terminator yes I love
that there were some really there's some
really fun ones that I saw a lot of the
fans do and I think that there's some
really great arguments made I think that
did although the Daniel Craig comment
the only fact that I saw there was that
Daniel Craig did say he did want to come
back whether or not it's kind of
speculating that he knows one movie is
my point they were pretty good I will
say as far as here in all their pitches
when Perry was said final destination
Star Wars I said that's gonna sound
ridiculous and I think that she fought
for it very well I think that she didn't
just for the way that I heard it wasn't
really necessarily just about the movies
themselves it was about the general idea
of what final destination is all about
and combining out with Star Wars I
thought that was a really good argument
and I don't think the other fighters
kind of combated that at all got an
eyelid Wendy thoughts so all right when
I first heard the equalizer and what is
it taken and then I heard bond and
Bourne and immediately I thought wow
that's not really yes it's colliding but
it's two of the very similar things
together so when Perry said Star Wars
and final destination it kind of what
the hell is she thinking and as more she
explained it I was like you know I could
actually see this working not to mention
I do feel Liam Neeson and Denzel I love
them both but they are getting a little
bit older action scenes are not gonna be
as cool and you put the two of them
together I don't know and I just can't
see bond and Bourne working together I
just don't feel like these two as actors
would you even be able to get along on
set that was the thing that I like that
pitchin born yeah I and bond I just
don't I just think that they came back
at you stronger I don't think your
arguments were strong enough as far as
why it should happen because I liked
your I liked your initial pitch best out
of the three of them I just think that
perry fought for the best alright dare
you have it both the votes go for Perry
Perry never will she is our call
very well played Roka gone with one
Harry Met Sally meets mr. and mrs. Smith
let's head out to the balcony for Union
of flash and friends check it out ah man
hey guys welcome back to movie fights
live I'm Joestar this is Roxie stryer
and we were asked to kill some time with
Marvel's Tony Revell Laurie hey buddy
what we just realized this is sort of a
flash and friends reunion and I you play
a flash I play a flash sure so we have
two questions one is is flash still
alive Barry Allen is still alive yes as
far in the Justice League I believe he's
still alive
okay well the fan of Barry Allen so I
was Flash Gordon still alive Flash
Gordon um I think the song goes Flash
Gordon is alive I think he's alive as
for my personal opinion as for if flash
is still alive in the MCU post infinity
Wars this is not confirmed this is not
me saying anything this is just my own
speculation my own thoughts just cuz I
want to have my own thoughts he died
taking a in the toilet okay
that's my hundred percent confirmed
Flash Thompson died on the toilet
someone tweet Kevin confirmed he
died on the he died on the toilet stone
that's one of the stones I mean who
wouldn't have died on the toilet your
peaceful you get some release it's like
you know this is what happens when they
tell us you just stretch
is that what a toilet Stoney's and by
the way toilets don't totally
brown-colored but I'm like whoo I love
you so much guys we have some we have
some donors to call out Christian
Jackson thank you so much Jason Dolan
thank you so much John roca you're in my
shot thank you so much Chris Cassidy
thank you so much and Danny petrushka
thank you so much you guys for donating
you can still donate go to screen
junkies comms last chair it max less
charitable event and make sure you
donate I think we can hit 45 I think we
hit 50 today thank you guys so much for
being a part of this dude thank you so
much for doing this I know I mean listen
I love women in film I think it's great
I recently worked with a female director
Hannah Fidel and she was phenomenal work
with and she has hardship so you know
it's hard for a female director or
female producer anyone in the industry
because you're giving so much crap just
from the beginning so it's it's my honor
to help in any way I can
man n is the beginning you guys we are
going to go back to Sasha on the couch
she's got the crew of gamer fights you
guys take it away if this is any
indication of what's going to be
happening in this fight this couch is
chock-a-block with bad ideas and I can't
wait to introduce you to all of them
starting with Spencer Gilbert his body
is a stretch goal
we've got oMG it's Firefox tableau port
NAT Rob game over Greggy and Nicole Z
our gamer fighters you guys games versus
movies what is actually more difficult
to fight oh I I don't know I would say
games I would say games cuz there's more
there's more complexities to it because
you you involve yourself in the game and
you're the one kind of narrating it
whereas you know you're watching movie
it's already narrated for you it's just
lazy that's what it is everybody always
says Citizen Kane is the greatest movie
of all time so Pam what is the greatest
game of all time well I mean people are
probably gonna judge me for this but my
favorite game oh no my favorite game of
all time is Chrono Trigger for the Super
Nintendo
RPGs it's got a good story it's got time
travel it's got amazing character
development
can't go wrong so this whole event is
about women in film who are some of the
great women in games greggy I'm going to
you Matt share that mic I think well
thank you so much man I think the great
you're talking about characters okay
okay then Lara Croft of course yeah oh
you agreement I agree I agree holy Lara
Croft 100% peach come on guys yeah she
keeps you in rescue all the time all
right yeah you know she should rescue
yourself like are we game fighting right
now what are you looking for from these
fighters um I'm looking for facts mostly
you know I want to play a clean game I
want everyone to care about what they're
saying no no no violence I want
diplomacy diplomacy yeah I don't have my
diploma Spencer you're sitting here just
looking cute you guys worked so hard for
this what does it feel like to actually
watch this event take place now it's a
lifelong dream come true look to pretend
that I did any of the work for this is a
lie but it's going so well so Thank You
Billy Thank You Bella producers and
thank to the people who donated and if
you don't put your money where your
mouth is right now I don't know what you
need because this fight coming up I am
so excited for these are some of my
favorite women from the internet from
the universe starting with our hosts I'm
kicking it over to you lady it's gray
Drake
Thank You Sasha isn't she a pistol my
name is grey Drake I'm the senior editor
of Rotten Tomatoes I have to tell you I
am honored to be here and I've never
judged before I'm a judging virgin but
this isn't entirely about me I am joined
by some of the fiercest most phenomenal
critics around the web and of course
over on the couch very important job
fact-checking is the fabulous Jen Yamato
[Applause]
okay so we're gonna get this started
we're just gonna jump right in here's
the question that you're going to be
arguing what is the most perfect movie
which is such an ill question okay when
I was posed this question I was trying
to think of a film that I was going to
enjoy and a film that I was going to be
happy to watch and also a film where I
felt it celebrated a part of myself that
I enjoyed the most and that's my
childhood so the film that I chose is
the 80s one film that we know and love
hey you guys that is the film that I
chose because I needed a film that not
only had action it had last it had heart
it had people that you really feel for
it had quotable lines it's a movie that
you can watch over and over and over
again if you turn on TNT right now I'm
pretty sure you'll probably find The
Goonies there or TBS or somewhere in
between it has actors that we've watched
like Sean Astin mature and not Josh
Brolin hispanos now who knew when he was
like pulling across there again it takes
you back to the 80s it takes me back to
a time that I love and who doesn't want
to go on an adventure with bikes with
her friends oof opening argument keep
going Ross strong I gotta say that when
we first talked about this I was
thinking about things like the
Godfather's I was originally gonna go
with All About Eve but you know what
there is a lie and that lies that
popular films can't also be art they are
and no film though I love both of the
films that you chose 100% no popular
film is more a piece of art in this
match than mine and that is Robocop
ladies and gentlemen
let me tell you something if Stefan
we're reviewing movies Robocop would be
the hottest club in town because it's
got everything this movie is one of the
best political satires of all time it is
a deeply profound human journey of a man
who comes back to himself and his soul
and his humanity he is Murphy once again
by the end of this movie it is a comment
on consumerism it is a comment on so
many things that are as relevant today
as they were it stands the test of time
in every way talking about the
militarization of police the the
privatization of police you're talking
about a world so riddled with desire and
want and greed that it forgets itself
that it forgets of humanity and in the
middle of all of that it's one of the
best action movies of all time it's one
of the best science fiction movies of
all time and it features two of the most
iconic death scenes of all time a man
melts in a vat a frigging waste it is a
rollicking sharp commentary on the
environment there's an awesome piece of
Simmons cinema at the same time you guys
I've been through 14 million different
timelines and Robocop wins every nothing
about this movie should change I just
want to pick up all those lies about
Robocop we got
all right well if we're talking perfect
movie to me that means two things one
it's flawlessly constructed flawless
flawless there's no ADR flubs or
whatever like going on the goodies we'll
get to that it is the perfect film for
just any occasion it is perfect it is
complete you can give up all of cinema
if you have this film and if that's the
case there's only one film that we can
submit here and that is the Princess
Bride
because the Princess Bride is a
perfectly made film it's got the
hunkiest bravest hero in history with
Cary Elwes as Wesley who like looks to
all the film history he looks to all of
the heroes of the past news like Douglas
Fairbanks I like you Errol Flynn I like
you and I'm gonna create the modern
version of the ultimate hero it's got
the best princess Robin Wright's
princess Buttercup is not only just like
beautiful of course but she's no
throwaway damsel like this is her movie
she's a major part of the story just let
her finish on the when she finished it's
not even just a movie about their two
arcs this is a movie with the best
supporting characters you got physic and
you go Montoya you got Billy Crystal's
miracle max you got Wallace Wallace
Shawn's Benzini like every small
character is memorable and none of them
are overused none of them are worked to
death and finally I'll just say that
this is the perfect bromance it's the
perfect comedy it's the perfect
adventure it's got the perfect amount of
thrills and no matter what group of
people you're sitting with no matter
what mood you're all in you can all
agree on the Princess Bride that makes
it the perfect flawless diamonds in
college town man this bride is a great
movie but you really glossed over the
fact that let's talk about the
one-dimensional character that is the
title character of buttercup
she is only there to be rescued she is
completely an object of every single
male within the film for whether it's
the prince or whether it's wesley and
the fact that what she does and how she
treats him she's a perfect example of
like if that was a dude we would never
respect that story or act like he loves
her in spite of how awful she is and we
love her because we love the film but
what makes Princess Bride great has
nothing to do with her and wesley has
everything to do with the cast of
characters around them I give you Andre
the Giant and definitely on tail Montoya
sorry say that wrong
those are the people that make that
movie great but it doesn't make it
perfect and I'm sorry I cannot call her
the best princess
I mean Cherie is the best princess we
already know that it's not even the best
robot we have the time frame we had
Terminator one which is not even the
best in that series that I would put
hands down I mean Robocop and he's not
even the best political satire we
already have Starship Troopers for the
Starship Troopers is list although I
love it is a stepbrother the brother of
Robocop fair joven did it better it did
it impeccably and wrote that I really
believe this i watch all three of these
movies and while I enjoy all of these
movies and I actually love the Princess
Bride there's a shot of Buttercup in
that movie that is out of focus because
that's how little she matters also
adding to that and so it's not perfectly
constructed adding to that most of what
we love about The Princess Bride is very
front-loaded it happens mostly in the
first 50 minutes when Wesley returns as
the Dread Pirate Roberts and he
encounters each of his challenges all
his adventures with Vizzini
and with Inigo and it ends about 15
minutes in and then we sort of lose
Wesley and we realize how much all of
this was dependent on Wesley and so
after that it loses a lot of the fire
that all of what we're quoting is in the
first 15 minutes and it's as if you had
a movie called Robocop or Robocop wasn't
the interesting character but you don't
because Robocop is an amazing
okay your opening argument I think you
lost this fight because you've said that
Robocop is the best action film and the
best science once I second one one of
not that doesn't make it perfect Robocop
is an awesome film but it's also an
awesome downer I mean when is the moment
when you're like oh I really want to
recognize that I live in like a
capitalist dystopia which we could see
did the once or but that come out it
tells you that right but it doesn't make
it perfect because like way you defined
perfect when we define perfect we said
what perfect meant was that it was a
movie that 100% achieved what I was
aiming to achieve that it stands the
test of time and that you would change
nothing about it all of those things are
true to this day of Robocop I would give
it some better special effects right
nobody was able to knock the nudies
because you know let me finish it is a
pure movie of child idealism and the one
thing I absolutely love about it is the
character of data it was a character of
color who was a part of this band of
rogues who had agency part of his
culture the fact that he spoke with his
character I'm saying he had agency
within his smartness he was the smartest
guy of this group he's way better than
our one dimensional buttercup there's
the difference meaning of your time and
falling into the bad poor horrible
tropes of your time and good know left
bad spin on and that is how much time
that we have oh my god I know we have to
go over to the couch let's talk about
check into the backs Dania model I would
like to say first of all I found this
ring a bell and
is a fact that Jen loves that belt I bow
I've spent most of this this wonderful
debate trying in vain to verify to
fact-check that Goonies is in fact
playing on TBS or TNT okay I will say
that I feel like we spent more time
started breaking down the Robocop
arguments and breaking down the Princess
Bride argument then making a case for
Goonies which I would have liked to have
heard Roth I would love to support you
on RoboCup but Robocop 2 is better than
Robocop
[Applause]
my god by anybody starring Gabriel Damon
of Newsies yeah tell me who because I
can't remember and Princess Bride I
think that Amy made a really good
well-rounded argument in favor of
Princess Bride
I think the gender politics argument is
an interesting one to have around that
film you're gonna have to make a choice
genuine I don't help you yeah girl you
guys you got a big one
yeah go ahead Daniel all fantastic
points I'm including how dope ring II
bells are this yes I do agree I would
have liked to have seen more see more
advocating for Goonies but I do think
that it is a testament to that movie
that everyone through fighting each
other and everyone mostly until the end
until the data argument left left two
days alone so I do appreciate that
unfortunately Amy as much as I loved her
argument the thing about the no II know
the no flubs was was clearly debunked by
by Rafi pants
that's her name you can't call her that
so for me it was between the Goonies and
it was between yeah the Goonies in
Robocop and the bear Hogan versus Vera
joven argument is it was a good strong
argument but I have to go with Robbie
pants on this one oh all right so we've
got one vote for Robocop jr. motto
suicide my friend well I will have to
say that it forced to make a decision
filled with the boxed wine rose' that I
found I would have to go with Jacqueline
because Muniz wasn't taken down and I
enough to shake what we all know about
Goonies however everybody is arguments
against Princess Bride as well argued as
they were by my forever love Amy
Nicholson did casting doubt I would like
to explore that conversation further and
we have more than 10 minutes yeah for
the purpose more Jose yeah for this
give it to kidding okay so this is very
intense this is exactly what we've come
to expect from this event so we've got
one for Robocop we've got one for
Goonies
I'm gonna break this tie because to me
the statement the out-of-focus shot of
Buttercup means that's how little she
matters I was like wow that torpedo huey
me oh it was brutal to hear it may how
god it hurt and but i think that the
passion and the strangely legitimate
reasoning came from roth for robot that
was not even her first choice that shows
how great that argument she was also by
the way both me and Amy picked The
Princess Bride I'm just here to these
women go let's have everybody run around
give a quick plug go where can we find
you a Tron tomatoes on the internet at
that Jacqueline on all your social media
platform I find a girl RT yeah RC Foley
right my plug is to thank you guys so
much for doing this again this means the
world to me these women are brilliant
they are magical they are phenomenal
phenomenal I don't move you fight very
often cuz I get to yell E you just saw
so you're amazing I love you I'm writing
for a variety The Guardian in Washington
Post everywhere Paul Scheer and I of how
did this get made are going through the
entire a if I talk 100 mazing and sorry
episode 5 we use a sided rolling dice
she's awesome
jr motto anything real quick from me on
social media at Jenny motto but I would
like to give my plug to all these women
who everybody should follow and also
women in film is really great really
great fundraiser is benefiting and I
think that's like the bama's thing to
happen at one time agent fabulous
Danielle I live here y'all know me
that's right
that girl stuff we'll talk about so
here's the thing now there is text
written out for me so I'm gonna go to
the page you guys very special guests
coming up next in every generation a
scoop stir is born and we just so happen
to have the best with us here tonight
slash today still the daytime here in LA
let's go to Joe on the balcony
congratulations Roth cornet guys thank
you so much for watching this show I
feel like we've been putting it together
for the last 17 years and it's kind of
cool and surreal that's actually
happened to I hope you're having a good
time you guys can keep donating to the
cause just like char nice Ellington when
John you Carly Perkins and Steven Garrow
did thank you guys so much you guys can
join in with them
and now for something I'm really excited
about because you guys unlocked it I'm
so excited
mmm in a world of non-stop news and
information it's sometimes hard to know
who to trust but into every generation a
scoop stir is born armed only with the
best scoops he will rise to meet the
challenge of being the hollywood's
insider's insider that's why i'm proud
to welcome to the show the man with the
best scoops in town
scoops mcgee ladies and gentlemen
how's it going Joe good I've been gone
for a while what'd I miss nothing
literally nothing has happened that's
great
sorry I haven't been around I spent the
last six months posing as Kevin Feige
dermatologist to get infinity Wars
spoilers turns out I could read the
comic books and Kevin you should really
get that mole checked out it changed
shape Joe
however committing that illegal act of
fraud has not stopped me from getting
the best scoops in Hollywood do you want
some scoops
yeah all right
scoop number one Peter Dinklage from to
Worf to Worf my source deep inside
Paramount Pictures publicity departments
custodians favorite Ralph's store tells
me that Tyrion Lannister himself Peter
Dinklage is high on the studio's list to
play a key role in their upcoming
big-screen rebook reboot of Star Trek
The Next Generation to be helmed by
patty Jenkins over the long Columbus Day
weekend before she starts doing Wonder
Woman - that's it's four days show the
scripts which is going to be written by
Quentin Tarantino's long-lost twin
Clinton maraschino is said to feature a
juicy role for everyone's second
favorite Klingon Lieutenant Worf and
jinkin the dink are excited about
teaming up to bring a whole new
dimension to everyone's favorite second
favorite Klingon who is everyone second
favorite Klingon dwarf but their first
favorite it's Chancellor gorkon
that Star Trek six as they'd say on the
klingon world of Chronos bucks cheap low
that's Klingon for what a scoop
it's going great
all right Jodi you want one more sky
only have time for one more scoop scoop
but it's a big one hey what you bought
at least two scoops it's like raisin
bran Captain Marvel coming soon to DC
that's right this one comes from one of
my most reliable source sources a mole
deep inside the offices of podiatrists
Armand Huggle jan-jan located just a
stone's throw away from the Walt Disney
Studios that is look that up that is
100% true my source tells me that DC is
perilously close to luring brie Larson
away from her role as Captain Marvel in
the MCU to fill a new role Captain
Marvel in DCU also known as Shazam turns
out that the Zachary Levi alleged Shazam
movie already in production is actually
a sham word play an elaborate ploy to
hide DC savvy move to win the comic book
movie wars through sheer confusion but
the mouse house isn't going down without
a fight
I hear Disney is countering with an
aggressive package including stock
options a multi-picture deal and a
lifetime supply of bunion removals from
nearby podiatrist dr. Arvin
Huggle jan-jan let's hope this move
keeps Bri free from DC to fight the Kree
for Mickey all right Joe
I hope you got your money's worth
that's all the scoops I have my lawyers
have told me I shouldn't stay in one
place for too long the special counsels
after me for my work on the Russian news
site can we just keep goalie will do
thanks for having me good luck with the
events and I would like to give a shout
out to my personal favorite woman in
film agents of shields Mick Nasia
Barney's Beanery agent may my scoops
Godspeed scoops McGee you beautiful man
let's go back to mat Robin gamer fights
[Applause]
that was amazing welcome to the next
segment of today it's a returning fire
[Applause]
I am been robbed former host of gamer
fights current host of gamer fight to my
house we just don't air it we are going
to be doing an amazing fight here today
joined with my fighters from kind of
funny is mr. Greg Miller also joining us
oMG it's Firefox my favorite member of
the toaster ghost family we can't do
this without our amazing fact checker
from from yesteryear also a co-host with
me on gamer fights Nicole Z over in the
corner and rounding out our triple
threat of judges mr. Spencer Gilbert
anybody are you guys ready for this
fight it's an intense why you guys keep
asking me on here that reverse I called
you crab doesn't work here it's gamer
fight segment inside of a bigger movie
fight so watch out here we go your
question is what video game that doesn't
already have a film franchise deserves
its best movie adaptation Pamela I'm
gonna go with you first so when I when I
got this this question I immediately was
like okay so I can't be positive about
this because I'm coming from a place of
frustration I'm tired of my adaptions of
my comic books of my my favorite books
and things like that just being
completely skewered in movies so I want
an experience that I know will translate
well from the game story to the movie
story so I went with life is strange
because it was one of the fewest games
that I ever played all the way through
that made me cry that really made me
feel the weight of my decisions had a
little bit of the sci-fi element that I
had you know max can manipulate time a
little bit you got to see the benefits
and the destruction of friendships based
on your decisions it's very real life
it's something that you can actually
feel in the game and feel in the movie
because one thing that you guys have
with your choices is yeah they're great
games and I love them but are you gonna
get the same experience out of
game as you would from movie just saying
throwing shade before I even get to talk
well my choice was something that's near
and dear to my heart of course fallout 3
which is an interesting choice I feel
like so if cinematic post-apocalyptic
Washington DC doesn't do it for you and
if iconic 50s ish era music still
doesn't do it for you I feel like the
story is so meaty and there's so many
side quests and so much DLC that you can
pull from four different stories and
it's such a morality based game and it's
like you know is this main character
gonna join what facts are they gonna
join how it's gonna how is it gonna
affect other characters and other
companions and stuff like that and I
like how there is no define you are the
lone wanderer right there's no defined
main character so it realistically could
be cast by anyone it could be female and
you know what I feel like it's something
that kind of it it just holds up he's 10
years later you know what or never
changes what's your game Matt 3.1
million units sold in three days my game
of course is god of war on the
PlayStation 4 the hotness right now
coming from Sony Santa Monica that's so
many of you are enjoying don't worry we
won't spoil the ending right here
anything I'm sorry pan was that you
saying you like vegan just making sure
it's literally the only reason I bought
a ps4 Pam if you if you want mine this
is my moment judges I'd like that put on
a permanent record
I hear about God of War everyone
listening and watching is this it took
Kratos a character who was as
one-dimensional as a character can be
ice cream every line I have when I need
health orbs I have sex with a woman I've
just beat things up you don't know what
you're doing and gave everything a
purpose here he is a father suddenly on
his own with this boy
how will he raise the boy how many times
will he say boy he will take him on an
epic journey that sounds simple let us
get to the top of the mountain father we
need to get there and spread the ashes
that's it but the shenanigans they'll
find along their way that is where the
movie becomes the movie Kratos I'm
casting is the rock of course to give
him some depth the rock as well a
character right needs him the most
action he thinks I'm going back in time
for at Reyes I'm getting corey haim from
The Goonies era Boney's care for this
stranger one of the first big fight you
know the fight amazing fight we're
bringing in sir you and my Reger and
we're getting him jacked alright
I mean I'm gonna come in with cheese and
just grated on these three McGregor for
the head I'm Amir now I'll just run this
whole show if you this man win but we
need a voice for am Amir right we're
gonna go find Mike Myers and that's why
God of War will be the best video game
ever all right life is strange fallout 3
gotta four guys what's going on so my
biggest issue with life is strange is
we've already got that movie it's the
butterfly effect and I think my biggest
issue with gotta warm is that I mean
it's beautiful thank you but I feel like
you know you got your father you got
your son where the ladies at affray
right there who I'm casting as
Evangelina Lily thank you okay but for
starters fallout 4 all the Fallout games
have been an experience that the player
has because they customize the game to
how they're gonna play how can that
translate into a movie how can you
create
that same feeling in a movie Pam could
you make it any easier to say why your
game shouldn't be a movie both of you
called out the decisions and the choices
you make linear storylines you were
choosing between actual storyline
options that end up in a different you
know like and showcase like you have
this end story from your decisions it's
not like well I'm just gonna go kill an
entire faction just because I feel like
it today and then I'm gonna go back on a
save you can't do that in a movie and
that's what part of the fun of fallout
but I think that's why it's interesting
cuz it's like as you're watching it like
are they're gonna go with the
Brotherhood of Steel or are they gonna
do this and it kind of it kind of leads
you on that journey but then you would
just sit there in the movie and go I
would do this differently exactly and
that's what it will do with life is
strange as well 50% of your argument was
who you were gonna cast it wasn't
talking about the story of God war
weren't you're talking about how the
story of this God where we're talking
right now
it doesn't even touch base on the fact
that this is a crate ups that has
existed in a story line before I want to
know about the original story and people
are gonna be able to hey hey but if you
aren't gonna be able to get that same
experience because part of the allure of
the things you guys are talking about
our endgame flashbacks flashbacks
preposterous no I'm you guys that is God
were seriously one of the best games
ever and I want it really like seriously
love that game yeah but I don't think
that I would love a goddamn war movie I
don't think I would love a fallout movie
but I think anybody that I saw for life
has strange together we'd all leave the
theater crying feeling like I remember
what it was like in high school to have
how the weight of a situation oh this
person was bullied this person was
forcibly put into this situation you
have the emotional weight there is no
emotional weight to the part there's no
emotional weight no spoilers
the moms actually need to get spread if
you haven't played God of War that far
yet it's a lose the first time life
before the storm or anything we're the
original life is strange yeah which is
also episodic and also relied on your
choices to make you care
rely on the choices which ending are you
picking which side are you imitating
mine has a clear point A to point Z
excuse is a very linear it's not like
it's not like an open world there's not
a lot of exploring there's not a lot of
things you can pull from it's like I'm
gonna go do it I'm gonna go with them
out I'm gonna do this I'm gonna fight
this oh you're gonna be four hours just
wandering off well that looks like
something over there one or wander
wander yep it was awesome you
possibility for great moments in your
Fallout game I'll give you that for sure
the robot underneath the White House
that thinks he's Thomas Jefferson when
here's the thing I can't fall out for it
you haven't played fallout3 it's been
ten years your character right isn't an
interesting character you make your
character interesting how are we gonna
go into this character on screen and
have them make the choices that matter
to you are you gonna save the feral
ghouls or kill the feral ghouls what are
you gonna do how are you gonna know
which ending you are choosing because
this is your thank you we are gonna
alienate a lot of fans here there's only
one true ending okay but my final
argument is if you were at casting for
Kratos he is one of the most prolific
gamers or Gatemouth Yorkers in a game
ever he's oh yeah dude his fortnight but
I don't know if you've seen the hype
around Jason Momoa saying that he wanted
to play Kratos and I think that would be
by far the best Kratos ever okay just
saying oh can you go for the rock who
has literally turned down no movie ever
mm-hmm that's why it's time for the rock
on the map with a movie that shows his
emotional range okay we've seen plenty
of his range everybody's arguments
Nicole any anything I hate to point out
she didn't find enough say if I commit
to an ending before the movie comes out
then I'm gonna be disappointed and I
want to enjoy him just like all the
gamers who want me don't get the ending
Chloe would you want to
wouldn't let her die screw Arcadia Bay
with the one true ending I don't care
look call any facts that were wrong or
you think we're better few facts want to
point out first of all Pam said it she
does not like fighting and I think after
this we can prove that that's even
correct yeah I didn't enjoy any of this
fallout has more more music from the 40s
and the 50s and I just want to say that
I think everyone had really great
arguments but I if I have to pick a time
to pick one fact the strangers name is
Balder and he's way to introduce teas
introduced as the stranger Wow right now
and say that now is really uncool Matt
thank you so yeah let's let's go through
some picks what do you got Nicole who do
you think I have the best video game
franchise here um I think everyone did a
really great job and Everett we're very
proud of themselves they make really
great arguments but I do have to give it
to Greg and God of War and here's why it
is the grating cheese Abzu MacGregor and
it is shrek is love shrek is life voice
and I think that it's actually that adds
up that's fair thank you shrek wins yeah
I gotta say Sonya and Pam you really
brought it but you never had the counter
for Greg bringing up the the player
choice aspect and how you're gonna
resolve because this is a linear movie
there's only one story with the
beginning of middle and end and Greg you
just painted a picture for us thank you
thank you everybody Jason Momoa though I
guess
I looked at I googled got a war movie
and Jason the Mo's like I want to be in
that movie I'm like alright get behind
that and if he brings it up at the fight
I will I won't uh I lose but you didn't
so I do not want to know how Aquaman
pans out before I give him any other
we've got two votes it sounds like we've
got our when it's great
[Applause]
no spoilers and a lot life is strange I
can't play that life is strange
that's very find you on the internet mr.
Miller
oh you can go to kind of funny calm ki
nd a not like when they put it on the
other thing and they sped kind of yeah
Sony where can people find you I'm at
oMG it's Firefox everywhere Lauren 13
all across the board on social media but
you can see my content youtube.com slash
toaster ghost very nice Nicole Z where
can people find you in the Internet
I'm a Nicole's eat and I Kol easy and I
think it's a really awesome cause and I
just think that everyone here should be
very proud of themselves yeah you were
you're everywhere thank you guys this
has been a very special gamer fights
we've had a blast if you want board
gamer fights please make sure to tweet
directly at Spencer Gilbert owe him to
bring the show back Jeff sent him as
many tweets as possible pictures all the
things do it all is free show going
anymore
yeah Spencer Gilbert
[Music]
you don't oh hey welcome back to Monday
Night Raw
and Dan we have a very special guest on
the show give a round of applause for
Danny man back again thank you very much
it's the Candy Man here to give all you
kiddies a sweet tooth what's that sound
you've been missing I feel what it is
King you know I was tainted Trump's
place in Atlantic City this weekend I
was getting some workouts in and I got
to tell you well you nerdz up there was
seeing the new Justice League movie the
Candyman
was crushing shows left and right I was
in Jersey but it was more like infinity
sure and by the smiles on their faces it
was an infinity score Varick they're
very good I'm just glad you know we're
celebrating women to film I think the
best way possible with the Candyman Oh
so Katie woman thank you for joining the
show we really appreciate you being here
yeah dudes just hanging out on women in
film day you know what I'm a breath of
fresh air I am what is known as the king
size Snickers bar when you go out
trick-or-treating for Halloween all
y'all a bunch of fun size peanuts next
that's true candy moments my new
favorite comedian candy woman I'm with
her on everything fired I I believe
after that performance I believe this is
yours man oh I shall God's hope with my
life this has been fun this has been
great enjoy the rest of my women in film
thanks for unlocking this this is a good
time party
[Music]
gotta love that neck you guys I am here
with some of the most incredible humans
working in this industry I love them
beyond anything I'm feeling much calmer
after our movie fights which went very
well except that I was a maniac
these women are charging driving forces
in this industry so I want to get a
little bit of advice from them for any
of you out there that are looking to get
into this field or another creative
field Katie Walsh is one of the jurors
who decides which films are going to get
the finishing funds from women in film
it's one of the things that we talked
about earlier in a video some of the
most incredible things that they do
because then it allows us to see
up-and-coming female filmmakers so I
want to know from you what are you
looking for when you're watching these
films
I'm always looking for a really unique
voice a really strong point of view I
mean I think the best films are ones
that are personal and specific and
people who are true to their story just
telling their story and not trying to
please everyone and I think women's
perspectives are so underrepresented in
industry that it's so important to lift
those voices up and fund them and give
them support and money and just say like
yes go tell your story and we want to
know what your story is and just make it
as personal as possible Alecia Malone I
love this woman so much she came back to
us tonight so generously for one of my
favorite bite did my hair look at this
hair first of all fancy you're so fancy
you have a book out let's talk about
your book for a little minute what was
one of the most interesting that you
things that you learned in your research
that you didn't already know about the
history of women in this industry and if
you haven't read it backwards and in
heels is the book you need to be reading
right now yeah well I was so surprised
to find out that at the very beginning
of the American film industry they were
way more women producing films directing
films running production companies
writing films more opportunities for
women than there ever has been since so
I wanted to know what happened to those
women and who were those women and can
we take some inspiration from them so
that Hollywood doesn't always need to be
a man's well
you inspire me every single day of my
life you do you do oh my god in addition
to women in film that we're supporting
tonight there is a Facebook group that
you helped start called we rally talked
a little bit about that yeah it's called
we rally it's made by a bunch of
wonderful women like you we thought we
have so many great male fans and viewers
and people who really want to support
women and they want to do the right
thing so we thought we'd bring together
men and women for a Facebook group where
we discuss some very thorny issues we
get into some deep things we also try to
celebrate women who are working in this
industry and it just makes me so happy
to see these young men joining in on
this cause yeah that's the greatest
thing of all is that we have a lot of
great men here tonight these ladies
speaking of working in this industry are
champions you are one of the best
critics I know Amy I really mean this
you're one of the best lady reporters
they're making love right now that's how
intense it is
I love reading your work because even
when I don't agree with you I'm inspired
by your words every single time so what
I want to hear from you is how do you
sort of manage the balance of talking
about what's important to you and
meeting the needs of a business yeah I
guess I just trust that whatever I find
really interesting will be interesting
to somebody else because that's the best
thing about writers is like everybody
who writes everybody who has a voice
everybody at home who writes we all have
a point of view that's interesting to
people like when people think too much
about writing for what does everybody
want to read I think that's when young
writers really get lost astray it's like
really focus in on what you find
fascinating and that's where we each
other doctors there's a right answer and
criticism not because there's like a
good thing we're all supposed to say but
because what does that person say
because you're getting in their point of
view and you're understanding how they
think of the world and that's what I
love about reading everybody John I have
loved and admired you for years and
years and years you go to all the
festivals you tell me what I should be
looking out for what am I looking out
for this season well I just came back
from the Overlook Film Festival as genre
festival that's now located in New
Orleans and I really recommend it it's a
great festival for horror fans and I was
on jury there we awarded this Indonesian
haunted house movie called Satan slaves
by Joko Anwar which I highly recommend
especially if you like movies like
phantasm and also like I got a rub for
crazy rich Asians which is gonna be a
huge movie I don't think I've actually
played any festivals but it's coming up
this summer and I think it's gonna be
one to put on your radar thank you thank
you thank you Katie working the people
find you I'm on Twitter at Katie Walsh
STX and I write for the LA Times and The
Tribune News Service at junior mono at
the Amy Nicholson Alicia Malone at
Alicia Malone surprisingly and here with
us and we are so honored to have them
again thank you so much for your support
we can't continue to get contributions
maximum Lucca Gabrielle mares Gabriel
Martinez Albert Lorenzo thank you thank
you thank you for your support you can
still donate right now but you know what
you want it we want it I'll tell you
what my finishing funds are going to
it's puppet fights and that is up next -
Thank You Roth cornet and ladies Wow and
we've already had enough show we know
there's more Bellamy to fight do not
call them pop it that's racist the best
yeah we have some very this is such an
exciting fight our first debater you can
find them on perception check claims
welcome cucumber Thank You hello thank
you for being very happy to be here
thank you for having me
yeah well what are you doing before you
came here today ah well you know I was
drinking a little bit outside that was
nice it was fun I could smell alcohol on
your breath
we were driving also from perception
check please welcome chunk yeah
Oh everybody um are you related to
Grover no last time I checked you know
him as hashtag Botanica sour-faced mr.
Mike Carlson hi he'll good to be here
this is a thrill to be debating puppets
I've been calling the board for like
what feels like a decade now yeah what's
your beef with puppets no gentleman
gentleman felt it friend
I felt it friends I honestly this is the
most comfortable I've ever been on movie
fights to be frank I want to say that I
have actually brought a friend as well
sort of events yes I have a lot of
people don't know this but I have a son
did not know that yeah I thought you
were impotent no but no no I'm very
potent okay and I have a woodshop as
most people know I'm a woodworker I knew
her yeah so my son is a bit on
conventional and unconventional he is
from job and his name is Pinocchio and I
wanted to just say he's here to to sort
of offer me support and maybe he chimes
in once in a while all right
he's giving up but a pretty derivative
name and look
well it's a classic name for a classic
wooden boy yes it is yes it is I'm so
excited and again the belt is on the
line how do you feel about the belt
being on the line right now for this
ridiculous matchup danielle has been
giggling her face off
since the puppets have entered the
studio I'm sorry I'm sorry
here is the question that will decide
the next the new movie fights champion
what is the best non-human character of
all time Wow Wow
alright let's start off with cucumber
alright I believe the only one and true
answer is Samwise Gamgee he is he is
loyal he's a hobbit he's he he is
perfect for Frodo he supports him
immensely and without him that that ring
would've gone straight to Sauron he's
the true hero of the story Frodo screwed
up multiple multiple times and Sam was
there to pick up the slack and save the
day
alright Samwise Gamgee sean astin thank
you umm chunk who's your choice I'm
gonna have to say Raphael from the Ninja
Turtles
I think he's that guy we all wanted to
be I know we all love all four turtles
because I really do but Raphael was the
guy you wanted to be he was the one you
identified Malta with that was dozen
words the one you identified with the
most and just flat-out the coolest all
right Thank You chunk Mike Carlson when
I was raising my son on the Italian
countryside I wanted to show him one of
the classic films one of the classic
trilogies one of the classic whatever
nine movies is called and I'm talking of
course about Star Wars and we watched
the Star Wars films together and ochio
and I his mother at this point had left
just to leave us alone in the
shed and I showed him who's his mother a
belt sander Cal I'd appreciate if you
kept those jokes when in a moment for
the child he's very sensitive anyway
this is my son we're talking about here
all right I'm so sorry yes I was saying
the Star Wars films and our character
our favorite character is a nonhuman his
name is Yoda all right and he's appeared
in seven different movies and yeah the
kind of eight actually because it's kind
of his voice is a little bit well I take
that back
it's seven because his voice is a little
bit in force wagon but he's not in the
first this is a character who can do it
all he can raise rocks with his hand he
can shoot lightning when he's dead
mmm-hmm he is a character who wields a
tiny little lightsaber he can jump
around the Imperial Senate he offers
sage wisdom and let's be honest he is
portrayed by the greatest puppeteer of
all time Frank Oz all right there you
have the three choices fighters fight it
out so you're talking about the same
Yoda that turned tail and ran outside of
a corridor like the reverse of die hard
he had no choice all right and leave he
lost to Joe he lost the city and he had
to go seek shelter for the record I just
like to point out that a puppet alton
friend made you his
yeah Yoda used to be used to be one of
our fabricated American fellows but from
colleges they decided to go with some CG
crap so but he'd lost a lot of
credibility with that CG let's be frank
CG is better than puppets
okay I can't flip around it's not
realistic when he's flipping around wait
the when he's fighting capture you you
guys were fighting Count Dooku I just
wouldn't believe it was fake fighting
Count Dooku my green screen you mean
killing an old man I don't believe that
you guys could kill an old man Anakin
killed Count Dooku he took his to light
showers and he sliced his head off okay
but but Yoda didn't yeah so that's
another thing they softened him up okay
let's talk about Raphael he's a hothead
all right he is somebody who runs off
and does whatever he wants he's a master
ninja 16 years old is the master won't
even let him out of the house young he
affects a strong fighter he is kind of a
leader of the turtles that you know we
savor and Donatello is but really who
gets stuff done
Raphael does he wears a trench coat that
doesn't even conceal his identity let's
be honest you can tell he's a giant
turtle
does nobody hasn't made a point of
calling him out on it
people are being polite to him when they
don't call him out they go well there's
a giant turtle over there I don't say
anything
be nice and him flying off the handle
all the time really gets the turtles
into more trouble just something we all
identify with as a character aging jerk
no emotion sometimes I think that's why
he's so important because he represents
all of us hmm
struggle that inner stroke that we all
lost you know all fight with and and he
lets it out and he makes us feel feel
right it's okay to sometimes to have
emotions we don't always have to hold it
back but we should hold it back when the
Foot Clan is involved let's be honest
those are a deadly gang of assassins
that we need to be stable we need to go
in with our heads on a swivel but we
need to be making sure we're making the
right decisions okay haven't heard a ton
about Samwise Gamgee into it he was
smashed by God right off the bat he knew
that gone was no good even when Frodo
did not he was prepared to go the
distance knowing that there was danger
in their midst and he succeeded he's not
gonna Frodo to the top of that mountain
to get that ring into Mount Doom for its
destruction t-that Frodo didn't need Sam
let's be honest yes there's a good
chance the photo would have had to jump
into the lava himself by day what
happened he also saved him from shoe of
the giant spider but maybe they wouldn't
have been worried with I was if
what's his face I have been annoying oh
well I'm leading them to the thing and
if Sam wise was not aware of God's
duplicity then I think that that yeah
Sam wise it's just kind of an accidental
kind of guy he just he was bad nothing
but loyal and the best friend anyone
could possibly have hope once ago he had
to go to France Raphael was a hero all
that time
emotions going on but in the end they
came through they learned a lot that
became a rock closer yeah the girl a
little bit look
Yoda burned the set of the sacred Jedi
texts in the last Jedi alright no he's a
guy who is willing to throw out the baby
with the bathwater if it makes sense
alright cuz he understands how pointless
being a Jedi is he's willing he's a
progressive thinker he's like an Elon
Musk or Jeff Bezos in this era Wow is
there gonna be a space Amazon in the
next if Yoda has something to do with
alright Wow quite quite an argument
quite a battle let's go to Dan Merle
over on the key Dan cam listen I'm not
gonna lie I thought going into this that
this fight was a bit of a joke I'm sorry
so I was all ready to you know have fun
and then vote for Mike this is not a
joke and Mike you just got job by two
felt in America and for me and I'm not a
bit legitimately by far the best
argument with Samwise Gamgee easily wins
this round thank you very much all right
that's one for cucumber Daniel Radford
[Laughter]
[Music]
analysing the arguments this is purely
based on the arguments I have to agree
with Dan you all do really good like I
found great things about every argument
the things about Raphael being too young
and not being able to leave the house
the stuff about Raphael and his inner
struggle and that it's ok to have
emotions was a great argument chunk but
overall cucumber really got me with the
Samwise Gamgee
[Applause]
this is your house you go to blame your
son oh you did this to me you're letting
my dad we came home from work after
getting fired all right I wanna thank
Mike Carlson I want to thank cucumber I
want to thank Chuck
uh you can find these guys on perception
check and cucumber will you come back
and defend the title oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah Mike I think you should
challenge him one of these days I'd love
to challenge him all right maybe we'll
see a rematch of that and this is truly
a great moment in sports thank you
everyone
we're not even done yet Wow but what an
honor to preside over this fight let's
go out to the balcony and see what's
going on the party about the knee Roland
hey guys oh my god history's been made
cucumber is the movie fights champion
they just gave me a card that said Joe
do something to kill time hey guys
you can keep donating to women in film
like the following people hunter Chris
widely Todd
Emily Spencer and Mick help thank you
guys so much if it we've got to do like
another minute and a half you're good
buddy half of this you keep going Jay
get in here in coach come here buddy
Jay you know you're good man you're good
keep going
we got a stretch the producer if you
want to wait ladies and gentlemen look
they said Joe does stuff on a card and
that you know I made a decision guys
thank you again so much for tuning in
the show's been like two months in the
making
cucumbers our champion is our movie
fights champion it's a dream come true
that means myself ed Grier and who won
the second speed round gauntlet coy
jandreau will be fighting for an
opportunity to take on cucumber for the
movie fights title guys it's a new dawn
it's a new age for movie fights thank
you guys
much for joining in thank you guys for
donating again Laura Phippen we owe you
a huge thank you thanks to you we hit
our goal in one day 10k all of doctor
who were very happy that we have to
watch all of it all 27 days worth of
Doctor Who content were so excited we're
getting ready got if you watch your
favorite episode of Doctor Who I think
it's gonna be the don't blink with the
one with their eyes are too dry so they
can't blink just started watching no no
I'm just excited to see the episode
where he finally gets his medical
license guys thank you again so much for
watching thank you to all our amazing
guests this has been huge let's cut back
to Sasha para ver on the couch Sasha all
right guys I am here with big fat loser
Mike Carlson you're a fantastic writer
thank you yes but chunk and cucumber
making that debut can we please give it
up that was so real and now we have one
more huge fight to go Doug loves movies
fights we've got mark barnard --an vs.
Clarkie Wolfie vs. Sam Levine
whoo you got Mike you know I'm gonna say
Sam why he just he know he wins a lot
I've faced him before he's a very tough
competitor so I feel like if I have to
pick it Sam but these are all great
competitors you know I'm not gonna Marx
we're gonna disadvantage because he just
did the Marvel Marathon so he was spent
31 hours in a movie theater so my god
that's done it was mental state Spencer
Oh his mind has got to be just a full
diaper right now that's gonna be tough
to shake off I feel free man how did you
did you just sleep during Thor - how'd
you get through
we've got one more fight yes and with
that fight we have a new judge how do
you think doug is going to compare to
how I mean listen everybody loves a Hal
Rudnick I've been friends without for a
long time but you know Doug is kind of
an internet legend so I am excited to
see how this goes
obviously I'm a hundred percent in the
corner of Clark Woolf she is my girl I
believe in her and I believe in Doug to
choose the correct winner for this fight
Roxy you chose a lot of really good
winners this is thank you so much I mean
you are you are a woman of the people I
am a woman of the people and I don't get
enough credit for being a woman of the P
if there were to be another TV fight oh
who would you like to see face-off and
would chunk be one of those people I
feel like we could have a duel belt
holder Oh a hundred percent chunk is
invited and can take the belt at any
time and I'm looking forward to that
moment and which chunk does but I would
also say Matt Lieberman held the belt
for a long time you would be great Dan
Merle held the belt for a long time so
there's some really great fighters out
there it's a tough call I want to fight
again I want you to fight again okay we
can do all this but we're so grateful
for you guys for supporting this
incredible day this extravaganza thank
you for being a part of it thank you for
supporting women in film you can
continue to make donations and keep in
mind if you guys are watching this like
three weeks from now it's not like the
donations stop you can still do it you
can also volunteer you can be a part of
the organization but if you want to do
anything I think the most important
thing you do right now is watch some
Doug loves movies fights cuz this is
gonna get ugly this is gonna get rough
round and rowdy and I'm excited for it
Doug Benson we're going to you
I got my Tito's sunglasses on they're
not a sponsor of me my name is Doug and
I love movies good job you guys
today I brought together some of my
friends to have a fight let's give it up
for fandoms Clark wolf dum dum Sam
Levine and pencils mark barnardine
everybody's got a sponsor dan Morel is
gonna be checking the facts who's your
sponsor dan is on the couch she's also
gonna help us out and it gets a deciding
vote at the end of this thing but it all
comes down to what I think and I think
I'm the best person to judge to be the
final judge on a tribute to women in
film question clark is particularly
ready with several pages of notes it's
very intimidating is the best female
movie character of all time Wow yeah
shades back on argue it out let's start
with is there a specific order we should
go in Sam Levine all right here we go I
thought long and hard about this I
weighed all the options and there is one
clear-cut winner and her name is Ellen
Ripley from the Alien franchise this she
is not a woman you want to mess with
this is a gal who was working as a
Warrant Officer on on just a barge of
his ship just trying to get back home
from some moon colony just trying to go
back home and then all of a sudden
there's a friggin alien machine
everything is going wrong on this on
this flight home and everybody around
her is like oh I know what to do I know
to do and they don't know what to do
Ellen Ripley has to take charge she has
to save try to save as many other people
as she can but they don't listen to her
but
she's a smartest and they don't know and
and so she has to save herself and
that's exactly what she does she gets
out on that escape pod and she is trying
to not just save herself she realizes
that freaking alien is in there she's
got to save humanity if that thing comes
back to earth with her she knows that
it's all over so she does it she
defeats the alien only guess what 57
years later to have to do it all again
she is the only one who knows what that
thing is like and she tries to explain
to the company understand this thing is
a killing machine and the company said
'no no it's fine we're gonna send you in
armed Marines with you this time Allen
and she's like no those are Marines they
don't know what they're up against I do
and she goes in there and she makes sure
that that thing does not destroy
humanity a second time and then then why
are you yelling at me because I want you
to understand how awesome Ellen Ripley
is Doug Wayne if someone probably is is
that the bill yeah all right great I'll
come back to it then yeah we'll talk to
you in a little bit okay thanks for
coming by hey my pleasure happy to be
here what's your choice yes sir um that
was a great synopsis of the first half
of the Alien franchise I got cut off it
was probably the best part of Ellen
release trajectory thank you very
I can't wait to hear your thoughts on
the alien 3 my favorite uh so okay I was
thinking about what makes a great
character right and it's important
statement yeah to think about what
define an overall character it's a
journey and evolution a change but it's
also you know the things that make up
this character it's their look it's
their lines and of course it is the
actor who plays them so for me the
greatest female character in all of
movies is Leia Organa it's Princess Leia
from Star Wars you know one of the the
reason there's so many reasons to to
love her but I think it's it's amazing
that we got to see her journey from
princess to general we got to see this
character's evolution from
the age of about 21 years old to the age
of 60 so she is a complete picture of a
woman we see her be young and fun and
energetic and rebellious then we see her
grow a little and and get a little
edgier we see her as a mother we see her
as a lover we see her as a general we
see her as a see her as the leader of
the resistance she is a complete package
and at the end of the day she's real I
think that's why audiences have fallen
in love with her over the course of of
five movies is because she gets to be a
real woman a real person and so I think
there's there's really no other choice
it's it's Leia okay no bail for you
because you you know didn't describe all
the movies I was describing her peril
what do you got for us what's your
choice mark well damn I mean that's
that's a lot to live up to there's a lot
to follow that's a lot to come on the
heels of I went with clarice starling
from wow I feel like if you're if you're
talking about a female character if
you're talking about a character who is
existing in the real world not science
fiction not alien places who's dealing
with real monsters that are actually the
worst human beings on the face of the
planet do you find a character like this
to find a character who walks into male
spaces afraid but still goes that is
that is what courage is that's what it's
not not being afraid it's being afraid
but selecting despite that and her
entire mission is to wrestle the
monsters of the world to the ground
she's racing away from her own inner
trauma into the maw of people like
Hannibal Lecter and Buffalo Bill and
it's her job to make people safe it's
her job to conquer her own fears to help
conquer the worst of humanity and like I
love both of these other movies I love
both of these other women but you know
one of them was a damsel in distress for
most of the movies and the other one was
written to be a man so that's just what
I'm saying I'm going clarice starling
I'm going strong Wow okay I like that I
like all of what you guys said I the
thing about Clarice is I wish she
learned how phones work because at the
end of
the end of that film she says dr. Lecter
after he's clearly hung up other than
that it's very strong choice they don't
teach that in the FBI but now I'll leave
it up to the three of you okay to find
it out all right well I want to pick up
on what you said damsel in distress and
I think and I think that is the
absolutely perfect phrase to describe
why Ellen Ripley is absolutely Queen
among these three
what is princess Leia's most famous line
help me Obi one only hopes to aim an old
white man and what is Clarice Starling
'he's most quotable line exactly she
doesn't have one what is it yes she was
a big girl sir no most quotable line get
away from her you this is a woman
who doesn't look outside for help this
is a woman who knows she has to do it
herself if she wants it done well I
gotta answer the damsel in distress
claim when it comes to Leia because I
you know I did actually just rewatch all
of the movies and and help me obi-wan
Kenobi you're my only hope
is is the most iconic line says you guys
but talk to a generation of women who
grew up watching her and watching her
grow from being the princess who is in
distress to the general who is leading
the rebellion alien or alien
oh that's not true because much like our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ Ellen
Ripley after heroically taking her own
life to once again save humanity
resurrected believe it or not but to
your to your point actually I I liked
that every choice Leia makes isn't
perfect the question isn't who is the
who got everything right the first time
they did it it's who is the best female
character in movies and guess what you
got we're not perfect nobody is perfect
and the thing that women
film have been forced to do forever is
be perfect and that's part of the reason
why I picked Leia is because every
choice she makes isn't right but we see
her deal with the consequence of that
and we see her fight another day and we
see her pick herself up and keep going
that is what makes an important
character pardon my french but I thought
the saying was get done
both men on the table have said
and I have it I was referring to the
female alien I'm not I'm not gonna
disagree with you but the same could be
said of all three of these characters
they all are imperfect they all make
mistakes they all grow the difference is
Clarice Starling has the benefit of the
FBI being behind her Princess Leia has
the benefit of being born a princess and
then becoming a general with the
disposal of an entire army and fleet
Ellen Ripley has herself to depend on in
the shooting as herself and her
underwear and a cat that's right
I hate to jump in because the same time
is up by they I just mean voices in my
head that's cool that I should probably
ignore and one last thing about Clarice
because we've one of these characters
led the actors playing her to a Best
Actress Oscar Oh only one of the bunch
I'm just gonna say Jews gonna say all
right that is true
Sigourney one for another role right
sure gorillas in the myths yep not that
great baseball team the gorillas that's
our fight and we gotta go to Dan for the
facts yeah she was nominated for
gorillas in the mist
oh did not we have not win nominated two
years earlier for aliens actually we did
twice in one year she's not a Supporting
Actress for working girls two different
category
be strong pretty strong that is pretty
strong effectually that's all I have
would you yeah that's it because he
weren't really dealing in facts it was
all just a strong woman trying to take
down a couple of scruffy-looking
nerf-herder what do you got for us
Danielle well I'm at this I mean I get
I'm not doing any of those social stuff
so this is a good fight
first of all he's an amazing fighter on
choices um yeah everyone had very strong
choices I loved Clark's idea of Princess
Leia and getting to see like the full
evolution of that character I loved mark
talking about how Clarisse has to deal
with the real world monsters and going
in when they even when she's afraid but
I have to say that Sam just kept hitting
it and hitting it and hitting it with
the really great arguments about Ripley
not having anyone else having to be by
herself having iconic line that iconic
line all of these arguments to me were
very very strong so gotta go with Sam
mm-hmm I was the other way or I was a
different way there - what are you
saying
I actually went with Clark because I
felt everyone had a great opening like
all of you when you gave your opening
pitch I was like I agree with that okay
nope I agree with that okay nope I agree
with that so it all came - when
everybody was mixing it up and I felt
like you know the core debility thing
didn't really have much sway with me and
the award thing is great but that also
didn't hold much sway and I thought that
Clark in the middle really diving down
into her character and and what I
admired was taking an attack from one of
her opponents and turning it into this
is why this is the strength of that
character that's what went out for me at
the end of the day so I actually know
the argument about the flaws was great
yeah absolutely yeah all right well I
guess I've got to decide this thing and
I'm going I'm going with Dorothy from
The Wizard
[Laughter]
you know all three characters are super
strong women who you know like you guys
said with your with their flaws and
their strengths and it's a it's a really
rough decision I have to make here I
wish that one of my felted friends was
here to help but I'd have to say that
for me the most enduring character of
the three chosen here has to be Princess
Leia so I'm giving it the loves movies
smites
that's weird to say thank you guys for
playing and for being here and let's go
to Roth and the ladies of screen junkies
out on the balcony - you have fully
supported the screen junkies aren't
evers with women in film god bless you
[Applause]
cucumber for weeks
congratulations - cucumber thank you
thank you
Roxy oh my gosh thank you guys so happy
every single one of our guests and hosts
that has been with us tonight thank you
so much for giving us your time thank
you yeah everyone else at the team I
love you guys thank you and good night
[Music]